since the election
republicans have been passing a series
of i guess you can call them voter
reform laws that
seek to kind of pull back a lot of the
leeways that were given because of the
pandemic
to make it simple because of the
pandemic we made voting
very very easy and with that ease comes
a lot of insecurity
so a lot of republicans have been saying
okay let's let's pull back a little bit
of the mail in voting let's reduce some
of the hours
but for the most part a lot of these
bills still leave a lot of open space
for democrats
that's not stopped the media and
democrats from saying these are voter
restriction bills because they want to
retain
every single leeway
they got during the pandemic right now
in texas there's supposed to be a
special session
where they're going to vote to actually
have some of these reforms but the
democrats have fled on three
private jets to dc illegally to block
what's called a quorum so we're gonna
talk about this
and we've also got a bunch of other
stories south africa has has
it is it is getting crazy i mean the the
looting the violence the writing is so
severe you're seeing videos of
citizens just shooting at riders there's
there's even videos reporting to show
police officers joining in the looting i
don't know if that's true
and completely but there's a lot of
accusations showing cops loading up vans
so
maybe that's the case and so we'll get
into all this and we have a great guest
talk about what's going on
in texas someone who's actually now
running for the governor of texas
lieutenant colonel alan west is joining
us it's good to be back
with you tim thanks for having me right
on do you wanna just do a quick little
thirty-second intro just tell people who
you are well
just uh you know 22-year combat veteran
united states
army uh also a former member united
states house of representatives been
living there in texas since 2014 i'm the
former chairman
of the republican party of texas i
submitted my resignation
on the 4th of june and on the 4th of
july announced
my candidacy for the governor of texas
did people see that one coming
i think a lot of people thought that
there was something out there you know
but
uh we we kind of kept people at bay but
when i
put in the resignation from being the
chairman some folks realized that yeah
he's
he's looking at going into elected
office again let's we'll talk about that
too because texas is one of the states
that people really love
i mean for one everyone loves texas yeah
but considering what happened with the
lockdowns texas and florida are way up
there with what people
appreciate so we'll get into all that
stuff too we got ian chilling what up
everybody ian crosson over here alan
good to see you again good to be back
man i'm
excited to hear your story about how you
winded down with the um
with the head of the republican uh what
was it the
public texas yeah and uh how the
transition was so let's get into that in
a little while yeah
i'm also here in the corner i'm very
excited to hear some more of lieutenant
colonel
alan miss producer that's right i'm here
very special
i want to hear that wisdom oh my gosh
okay
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member
and you'll be doing two things for one
you'll get access to our exclusive
members only segments
which there will be one after this show
usually goes up around 11 pm and this
one's going to be a bit spicy
there's a big story that we probably are
we'll save that one for the members only
it's about a rainbow monkey you may have
heard this one but
we're gonna save that for the after show
because this one's gonna get probably
too spicy for youtube
but become a member because not only are
you doing that but you're helping us
expand and
you're actually going to get a preview
for those that are watching
of what the new website is going to look
like it is
alpha demo version but we're actually
using one of the articles
about texas that we have from the alpha
version of the site so you're gonna see
the site's gonna look fantastic and then
you'll know what your membership helps
support
so again timcast.com become a member but
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel right now
share the show with your friends post it
on facebook or twitter wherever else
with a subject matter what we're talking
about because that's the most powerful
thing anyone can do right now
as most of you probably know the big
tech company sensor they just censored
donald trump's speech at cpac where he
was talking about censorship it's it's
beautifully ironic it's a fire truck on
fire
there's one thing they can't stop though
when an individual decides to share
content that doesn't fall outside of
their nebulous guidelines they're always
trying to change the rules and argue
something
but as long as the content can exist
they'll try to suppress it
soft power soft pressure to shut it down
when you share it you overcome
every obstacle they throw in our path
but keep that in mind for all of your
favorite channels be a crowder stixx
hammer or anybody else
you got to be sharing that content so
let's read this first story let's just
jump right into it
we got nbc news reporting texas
democrats
flee state in effort to block gop-backed
voting
restrictions the lawmakers are on their
way to washington to advocate for
federal voting rights legislation
risking arrest by leaving during the
special session i just want to point out
very quickly
i love how it's always framed in the
media voting restrictions
voting suppression you give them an inch
to take a mile absolutely
and one of the things you have to
understand is if you go back to april of
last year
uh eric holder who is the chairman of
the national democratic redistricting
committee wrote an op-ed piece in time
magazine
and the title of that op-ed piece was
how coronavirus should permanently
change elections in america
and what did they lay out they lay out
the fact that they were going to use
universal mail and ballots which is
different from absentee balloting
absentee balloting is a control
mechanism uh you have to send in
like in the military you have to send in
requests for the ballot and it's sent
back to you controlled
absolutely but they're talking about
just flooding the zone with ballots that
are out there and one of the things that
we have
evaded in harris county which is the
largest county
in the state of texas third largest in
united states americas around houston
the county clerk down there wanted to
mail out 2.7 million ballots
against a voter registration role that
had never been reviewed
wow and now think of 2.7 million ballots
that just gotten out there in texas
which donald trump only won by 620 000.
now that's the type of thing that they
want to have they want to have 24-hour
voting
uh in texas so i guess we're going to
have polling locations at waffle house
and denny's and things of that nature
unchecked nobody watching and then the
other thing that they want is curbside
voting now curbside voting in texas
constitution
is very clearly defined if you are
you know unable to get out of your car
you go to a polling location
and you arrange for your ballot to be
submitted there at that polling location
they just want curbside voting anywhere
as a matter of fact
that exact same person chris holland set
up nine different curbside voting
locations
all across harris county now those are
the type of things that we're trying to
eliminate from happening
signature verification stop having poll
watchers republican poll watchers being
bullied and not allowed to go in
and do what they're supposed to do
watching the the ballot county process
but what is so funny tim because you
know i just flew up here
uh to tech to to dc i was on an american
airlines plane i had to wear a mask and
everything
but there's a picture of these democrats
flying up here on the private jets and
guess who's sitting on the front row of
one of those private jets
without a mask my state representative
retta bowers
wow throwing up the peace signs so i
really do feel represented thanks a lot
real quick um i also bet to get on that
plane you had to show an id
i bet they didn't oh no i had to show an
idea
right yeah were you able to board the
plane curbside uh no i was not able to
board a plane curbside and i had to be
on time
it was not a 24-hour window for me to
board the plane did the plane
come to your house unannounced without
you asking for it and then offer you a
ride
i don't really have a good runway see
it's funny i mean obviously i'm being a
little bit facetious but
with uh with these voting restrictions
it eliminates a lot of the security
basic basic security curbside i mean
when i uh during the the primaries when
i was in new jersey
i got a mail-in ballot for somebody who
did not live at my house
and i don't i don't know why it was a
legit full ballot and then
what am i supposed to do with it it's
not mine i don't i don't know it's
election mail i don't want to touch it
yeah but when you combine that with
ballot harvesting oh yeah
and the next thing you know someone
comes around and picks up that ballot
and then it is actually officially
counted
see that's what the left wants and the
other thing that i find so interesting
is that these texas democrats
who are really obstructing the
legislative process in the lone star
state they're up here talking about more
federal control of elections well the
constitution does not give the federal
government any enumerated power it has
not delegated any power
for them to run elections in the united
states of america there's no centralized
control but
that's one of the socialist tennis is
nationalizing production
not just economic production but also
all we see uh elections
they have to do it one grain at a time
they can't just come out but this this
hr one
that they're trying to do federally it
effectively nationalizes it does
elections and the point this is lost on
democrats the craziest things be
because it's not a republican issue it's
basic american civics
that each state has the senators
represent a state to the federal
government because we are a union of
sovereign states free and independent
states that's what the declaration says
so they each state has their election
and determines who they want to submit
as electors
yeah they want they want i i don't i
don't know where this myth or this lie
comes from but you have a very large
uneducated population of people
who genuinely believe a national popular
vote makes sense because they don't
understand that we are a united
states of america absolutely and it's a
representative democracy so
now all of a sudden when you read hr1
what does hr 1 says
hr 1 says that there will be no picture
id
anywhere in the united states of america
really and there will be no voter
registration role review
anywhere in the united states of america
really that they're going to be
universal mail and ballots that's going
to be the standard
all across the united states of america
so basically we're just going to mail
out ballots all over the place
and uh people can fill them out like you
just talked about it's it's
it's like treating our elections like a
raffle you know we i don't know you got
to take us got a number on it right
congratulations you won the prize well
you know what's so amazing tim is
and you know ian and i were talking
previously you know the times that i
served in combat
i was in combat trying to help people
establish voting
systems that now are probably better
than ours i mean
you know i would you know everyone
remember the purple finger
well now i mean i don't think we have
any way of really determining who's been
voting
where were you when you were trying to
set up the voting system that was in
iraq i mean
in iraq and then also in afghanistan we
were trying to uh implement these
democratic principles and and
fundamentals and now here
in the united states of america we're
eroding and undermining
our democratic principles and
fundamentals we used to be the gold
standard
show me another country in the world
that says we're just going to mail out
ballots
yeah and without checking without
checking that to me is absolutely insane
well it is insane but that's how you get
to one party control which is exactly
what the progressive socialists want
in america it's it's you know i look at
you you want your voting system to be a
well-oiled machine where each part of
that process is mappable you can track
this piece goes to this piece to this
piece to this piece
so when the ballot comes out we know
where the ballot came from we know who
sent it we know who got it and why
whether they went in person or they got
an absentee ballot which has that chain
of custody
now it seems like they're just trying to
turn into a splotch they can't track
where things are going you can't
you know we had that election i think it
was in north jersey where they found a
big bundle of ballots
all just tied together absentee ballots
and that it made no mathematical sense
so this caused a federal judge to say
do over that's that that we can't have
that
how are we supposed to have confidence
in the system well you can't and and
you know this is what has happened it's
not coincidental
so at the same time that we're trying to
nationalize elections and not have any
picture id no signature verification on
these mail-in ballots
we've got an open borders policy we've
got hundreds of thousand people flowing
into the state of texas
uh or planes that are all of a sudden
showing up in the middle of the night in
tennessee
well you know before we get into that i
want to mention something about that
you know those people get represented in
the electoral vote regardless of whether
or not they cast a vote
that's because the the left does not
believe that the census should be based
upon
citizenship they want the census to be
based upon
numbers and so they're flooding it in
because they want to have what
they want to have those districts that
will lean more so toward
the democrats i think it was tucker
carlson he was saying that democrats
want illegal immigrants because they
want votes something that affects i
think it was tucker
and the media went nuts it's funny when
you can tell when someone's over target
when they're like ah
he's a racist and a white supremacist
and uh he's technically right
but he misses one piece of it democrats
don't need illegal immigrants to go and
vote
they just need the census yes so in
california i think it was
um i think it was maybe heritage they
said that california gets about one
extra electoral vote because of the
amount of illegal immigration in the
state
the illegal immigrants are counted on
the census uh congressional seats with
an apportioned based on the census
number
not the amount of citizens and then you
get electoral votes based on how many
think about what you just said what just
happened in this last round of the
census
california loss an electoral seat and
new york i think too right
and new york too and guess who picked up
two texas
wow nice right when you have the open
borders and everything that's happening
and why did you see them all remember
they pushed off the census they pushed
off the results
and as soon as joe biden gets in was one
of the first things he does but
unconstitutionally by executive order
opens up the borders
and now we have the flood of people that
are coming in to be fair though
california's got
some pretty open border policies i mean
they're offering up health care to
illegal immigrants under a certain age
so you know they ended up losing i think
because of the mass exodus but i also
i'll also throw this out there as well
texas did gain but i think people are
fleeing california into texas
they are and there are two types of
people that are fleeing not just
california but illinois
new york new jersey coming into texas
and other successful red states you have
those people that
have given up they say i'm tired of it
i'm a conservative i want to go
somewhere where i can live under
conservative principles and policies
but then you also have the folks that
are part of the transplanted workforce
when you pick up and you move a
corporation or business
like we've seen state farm liberty
mutual toyota north america elon musk
coming out of these places and the key
thing is that we've got to convey to
these presidents and ceos
tell your folks that if they want to
continue to vote
like that stay but don't come here to
texas which you're trying to come here
because you want to benefit from our
economic policies
and the next thing you know is i call it
the locust effect
because california used to be a strong
red state oh yeah until like what 92 i
think
absolutely look what happened yeah have
you ever seen that comic somebody made
where joe rogan
he's walking from california to texas
and he's carrying uh he's got a travel
bag that says liberal policies on it
and then there's like a cowboy and texas
like whoa don't bring that with you yeah
absolutely
you know and a lot of people down in
texas will say we need to have a border
wall not just on the southern border but
also on the west side of texas as well
and
we need to have people turn in that blue
car and we can give them a red card
yeah you got to vote this way i mean i
moved out of philly and we're now
basically in west virginia
and i've got a bunch of people here like
you know i went to a store it was really
funny
because they were talking about oh these
liberals are moving out here and you can
tell
and then i laugh and i'm like yeah i'm
one of i moved from philly and then
there's eyes just like oh yeah they
squint and then i went don't worry don't
worry i'm not going to vote for any of
their
you know people because i'm i'm jaded
and they went oh okay all right well
vote republican and i was like
if they're good if they're good i'm not
i'm not playing those games anymore you
know
well you got to vote on principles and i
think that that's one of the things that
you're looking at
uh that is happening in the country is
that it is no longer so much about
political party it's about your
principles and values it's the
ideology it's the principle the
philosophy of governance because you can
have republicans that are progressives
you can have republicans that believe in
big government spending and things of
that nature as a matter of fact
the united states chamber of commerce
supports open borders why
because they want cheap labor and that
still hurts people too so you got one
political party that wants
because of quote-unquote votes or to
skew the census and the population then
you have another political party that
wants the cheap labor this
this is something that i was just
thinking about recently because uh the
southern poverty law center called me a
reactionary
yeah which is funny because i'm like
actually kind of a reformer which is not
you know reactionaries want to keep the
old system and i'm like i think we gotta
make a lot of changes to that system
i just don't want to burn it down and i
thought it was pretty funny because
policy wise
you know i'm thinking about the
political compass and like whether i'm
you know i'm like what are my positions
and so i actually i'm a political
compass i'm fairly left libertarian
but i think there's something that
easily like you can easily understand
this
uh i think you and i like america the
constitution
we like the country like our borders we
like our freedom and there's like a
difference in policy ideas
but the interesting thing about this is
if i say something like i'm actually in
favor of a basic universal healthcare
system with private insurance
that doesn't mean left anymore unless
you hate america it's i know it might
sound a little bit hyperbolic
or exaggerated to say like this oh
liberals hate america but i mean think
about this
when it comes to progressives how many
of the people do you see on tv saying
they want universal healthcare will also
proudly wave the american flag
and say this this country was found on
an amazing on on great principles that
put to the seeds of freedom
they're not going to say those things
they're not and think about what we saw
happen
on independence day you know coming from
maxine waters coming from you know corey
bush who
i don't understand how corey bush is in
the united states house of
representatives you got a picture
downstairs in your basement
of david dorn yeah we do and and that
was the police officer that was killed
because of the
violent uh protests that corey bush led
murderous riots a murderous riots and
now she's sitting in the united states
house of representatives a member of the
house judiciary committee
but corey bush stood there and said that
blacks in america still
aren't free and i'm thinking okay
uh i was born a blacks only hospital in
1961.
how am i not free but when they continue
to spew that rhetoric
and you still have people that buy into
it they listen to it then they start to
believe yeah you know i'm not free i'm
owed something i need reparations i need
all of these things
and that's why like i said last time a
show like yours is so important to get
this message out
especially to the millennial generation
in in your in your
i don't want to go too much into this
because i want to talk about this in
depth but you uh you showed us your
your announcement video for governorship
and you included the names of several
black men who are like pioneers and
founders in texas of i think
texas a m yeah uh state senator matthew
gaines who
uh former slave but ended up being a
state center in texas and
co-founded texas a m university and
prairie view a m
gt ruby texas state uh house
representatives
and then the very first black chairman
of the republican party of texas which
was founded by 150 black men norris ray
cooney
a houston a galveston businessman those
men
have they prove anybody with hard work
can succeed and they have accomplished
more than
than all of these progressive racist
activists
will ever accomplish yeah you're
absolutely right and see what they also
prove is that
they were not defined by what they were
they were defined by what they would
become
and what they did absolutely their
legacy that's the legacy but uh
you mentioned corey bush there's one
other person who uh
also helped lead the charge for these
riots and i want to bring this up have a
question about this uh that person
obviously was kamala harris
yes she tweeted out the link to donate
to rioters
who i mean some of these people i'm not
gonna list their crimes but there's some
very serious
crimes some of these writers who had
committed and she just blanket says
we're gonna we're gonna you know raise
money to bail them out
she said the texas house democrats
protest that's what she calls it a
protest shows extraordinary courage so
for those that are just tuning in
this is basically the democrats in texas
are illegally blocking a vote
by fleeing the state in private jets to
where dc i think right
yeah and kamala harris i wonder if
there's like a
is it is it illegal to encourage someone
to commit a crime is it you know
am i am i going too far by her saying
it's just courage did she actually
encourage them to do it
well that that's we call that being an
accessory
and people go to jail for being an
accessory but remember that the texas
democrats they did that in the final
days of our regular session at the end
of may
and they took a trip up here to uh
washington dc they were met by the
vice president and she called them
courageous and all of these things so
this has already been in the books this
was cooked up you know we went into a
special session last week thursday
and for whatever reason our speaker of
the house down there in in texas
put the house on recess and next thing
you know yeah they're on recess they're
up here playing around
in washington dc you know i feel like
when you get to the point
where the political parties are engaging
in
voting instead of policy like so the
goal of the democrats now is to affect
how the vote happens yeah that's that's
like the last
barrier to the system falling apart
because it's one thing when you have
everyone saying okay we agree these are
the rules
now let's play the game yeah now you've
got you're at the point where you're
you're you're
you know in the fourth quarter another
coach is saying we're going to change
the rules that rule doesn't count
we got to change everybody coming here
we're changing the rules we all agree
it's like no no something's up
if they can't defend themselves on
policy and they're now
saying we need to change the voting
rules
that sounds like they've got an argument
to make that sounds like how you lose a
country
and when you allow them to take such
petulant actions let's just
put it this way if republicans were to
do this exact same thing
what would be the number one story on ms
lsd cnn nbc what would be the number one
it is the story
republican voter suppression across the
country yeah but that's how they flip it
right just the same as when ginsaki
comes out and says republicans want to
defund the police
these guys that was a good one yeah but
these guys are masterful
in how they can manipulate language i
mean all of a sudden they have redefined
what infrastructure is
yeah you know and and so what we've got
to do we've got to get better with that
we
we've got to have that little strategic
uh you know cell that sits down and
thinks about
where they're going to go and how do we
block it we got to talk about freedom
the word the definition what does it
mean because it's an anti-government
slogan
it has apparently now yeah screaming
freedom in cuba's anti-government
uh it is but so we got to define freedom
what is freedom i don't have the freedom
to go next door and rip
food out of the guys refrigerator i
don't have the freedom to throw you guys
against the wall i don't have freedom
in that sense we have created
restrictions for a society in which we
gain certain types of freedom
and so voter restriction in a lot of
ways enhances freedom because it
it creates a restrictive system that
works better than just a throw it
against the wall and see what sticks
type of anarchy freedom where well let's
let's really do
let's put it this way um to help clarify
your point
if you had uh um an electrical current
go into water
those electrons are just free to mill
about yes you're not going to solve any
equations with it
but if you restrict the flow of those
electrons you can solve complex
equations
computers constrict the flow they
restrict and so i think about this
voting stuff
and restriction is is a false framing
they're trying to make it seem like
republicans are trying to take away
people's rights
when in actuality it's about securing
the process which guarantees your rights
so that someone can't come in and steal
it
for every for every uh mis
un unmatched signature for every ballot
that should have been rejected because
it was late or whatever
that comes in that negates your your due
diligence the hard work you did to abide
by the rules
absolutely but the thing is that let's
put it in a historical context if we
want to talk about voting
uh who has always been the party that
was against voting rights
who's always been the party that was
about voting suppression okay if i
remember right the 14th amendment
that was republicans you know and and
that was to give blacks
recently freed slaves which is the
reason why the republican party was
founded 13th amendment which the
democrats voted against they also voted
against the 14th amendment they've taken
that equal protection under the law
clause
and they perverted it the democrats were
the ones that came up with jim crow so i
really do find it kind of laughable
when you know everyone's saying jim crow
2.0 well you guys should know about jim
crow because you started
or you talk about the literacy tests and
the poll taxes
when you talk about the ku klux klan why
was the ku klux klan
founded the ku klux klan was founded for
voter suppression to keep blacks from
being able to go out and vote the same
type of blacks that founded the
republican party of texas and those
gentlemen
who became some early pioneers and so
that's what we have to start doing is
saying that
you know you guys have always been on
the side of this historically when you
want to talk about systemic racism
it's you guys oh they would know i love
that i love how they push the uh
the parties switched line
it's it's it's amazing to me that you
have people who don't read the news
don't read history you read headlines
they write headlines i know a lot of
people from chicago people have known my
whole life
and they tweet things like i'll be
talking to them and they'll say yeah
well the party switch and i go when
well it was like you know like a couple
decades ago like
the republicans decided to be democrats
and i was like why
you know what no no no no they don't
have an answer i mean certainly there
are people who have come up with answers
but it's remarkable to me
that by simply telling someone this they
go got it and they have no idea what it
means
they have no idea about the history or
the arguments they just go along with it
and that's what they throw at you when
you drop it you say you're close to west
virginia robert byrd
senator from west virginia was always a
democrat
he was also a grand wizard in the ku
klux klan
and he's the exact same guy that who
eulogized him at his funeral
joe biden yep and there's the same joe
biden who referred to
black men as predators now when joe
biden's standing there in tulsa oklahoma
and he's talking about the riots that
were there and the murdering of blacks
and the destruction of black wall street
he kind of missed this little great
historical anecdote that it was the
democrats
who did that or when you tried to take
you know
uh juneteenth which was the day that
blacks found out that they were free
uh down in texas in 1865 and
he tries to say that this is an
independent state well
you know they found out that they were
free because of a republican president
and republicans and what they did
and the emancipation proclamation that
was signed by abraham lincoln
not because of democrats and so they're
trying to steal history and
you you're right they just put out the
sound bank and so
yes the party switch and people just say
okay and
the more you say that the more you say
that people start to believe it but when
you anecdotally look at
think about this tim the longest
filibuster in u.s senate history
senate democrats against the 1964 civil
rights act
and they say that that was around the
time the democrats started switching but
i i'd like to play just a little a
little historical game of
walking through a brief a brief time
through history starting with what you
just said
democrats filibustering civil rights
okay from then
where was it where we were having these
police brutality problems
and still to this day the the the left
says there are police brutality problems
well it's new york it's l.a it's chicago
who runs those cities
yeah they're not run by republicans uh
you look at redlining and blockbusting
where were those policies implemented
why that was chicago
i'm sorry i thought chicago's been
democrat since like what the 20s
the greatest amount of failure is in all
of these democrat cities the greatest
amount of crime even though they try to
say republicans defunded police the
greatest amount of black on black
killing is in cities that are run by
democrats
but yet i have yet to see you know miss
patrice colors of you know black lives
matter the about marxist it has three
multi-million dollar properties i barely
have a house
you know just like 450 thousand dollars
but yet
i've never seen her go to chicago
detroit uh atlanta
dc philadelphia or any of these places i
got to correct you though i think
actually she has five houses oh but but
they're not they're not saying
but they're only like half a million
each and one of them is over a million i
could be wrong though
i think it's five okay i know there's
three that i thought three were
multi-million maybe the other two kind
of bring the value down
i think what happened was people
reported she had a multi-million dollar
house empire
okay but i'm pretty sure a lot of them
are like half a million but but i
thought
marxists were all about you know wealth
redistribution
and you thought right you know how many
people live in that house i mean
shouldn't you have like whole families
living in the house with it you know
just do as i say not as i do we we
there was a story a while ago we looked
up the data washington post ran the data
the crime per capita uh and the crime by
population and
the funny thing is when you look at
crime
by general population it's like number
one is new york but
sure it's not really fair to look at the
top ten cities and say who has the most
crime aha new york
well yeah new york's got a massive
population just by we look at per capita
and the funny thing is per capita you
actually have to remove
a there are some republican cities or at
the time
republican uh mayors because it's all
democrats
and so the left's response to this is
well democrats tend to run bigger cities
and i'm like that doesn't mean anything
why do they tend to run bigger cities i
don't know but i'll tell you this
if i i can grow up in chicago and you've
got democrats running it for generations
and they've not solved these problems of
racism and blockbusting and redlining
and segregation
when will you be like when you stop
voting for these people
because remember that movie shawshank
redemption oh yeah great
remember when uh brooks you know he had
been
there in the institution for so long
then finally he got to be free
but when they let him out of the
institution he was working at the
grocery store he just
could not deal with it because he had
become an institutional man
yeah and so i think that you have gotten
this institutional mentality of
victimhood
that there are some people that have
become so comfortable with
section 8 housing so comfortable with
the drugs and the gangs so comfortable
with waiting for the check to come down
you know you start to look at a lot of
the uh fast food restaurants and places
like that they're suffering because
people are getting paid to stay at home
and not work
i think that we have this dependency
cycle that is happening
and when you read uh alexander frazier
titles his you know democracy kind of
exists as a permanent form of government
you read that cycle
the cycle starts with dependence but
then
as you go through it you end up coming
right back to dependence and i think
that is what is happening
and one of the critical points is that
you get that apathy
and and and that's what we see happening
here in the united states of america
where people just comfortable
they're complacent in being a victim and
and that's what i
you know yesterday i opened up cpac on
on sunday
and i said we got this choice to either
be victors
or be victims and what conservatives
what america was founded on was the
individual
is a victor you know you know um
one thing i think makes everything a bit
easier is now that the democrats have
started admitting they're all racists
and white supremacists
so you have people like robin d'angelo
and you get these tick tock videos
where these are all progressive ultra
woke people flat out saying they're
racists
and white supremacists and i'm like
thank you for admitting it we've long
suspected it but i think you know as
many people have pointed out it's like
the soft bigotry of
expectations absolutely or i think it's
uh
as carl benjamin calls it white
supremacists with guilty consciences
well you know shelby steele wrote the
book white guilt and all you folks out
there if you haven't read shelby steel's
book white guilt you should read it
and that's how i got to tell you white
folks get hoodwinked y'all getting
hoodwinked man
i mean someone coming up to you and says
you're a white supremacist racist you
just say
get out of here i mean stop this because
but yeah oh
please don't call me that i'll do
whatever you want
here's here's you know i'm a corporate
ceo here's 10 million dollars black
lives matter don't talk to me like
well they don't want to break through
their window they don't want to fire
well you know what uh that's why we had
a second amendment you throw a brick
through my window
something's gonna happen you know also
we had yunmi park on the show she's a
north korean
she escaped north korea basically was
that the one to talk to the school board
meeting here
no no that was uh osra okay well i don't
talk here but she's the one fighting
schools yeah janmi was a north korean
defector and she she was saying how
freedom is terrifying hard and scary and
she almost went back to north korea when
she
had finally received freedom for the
first time because she didn't know
what to make she didn't want to make the
wrong decision and she was so used to
being told what to do so i think these
people that are institutionalized
have a similar life experience where you
know
the opportunity of freedom is it could
you could you could destroy it all
you got to grab it they will vote to
maintain those institutions
yes and the democrats i think are trying
to not necessarily
i don't think it's as overt but i think
it's a pressure
they're applying a certain pressure so
that in a long enough amount of time
they will generate
more institutionalized voters so i think
what's interesting is
there's long been this trope that
democrats want
hispanic voters uh and they're gonna
give they're gonna bring illegal
immigrants because they want to give
them
uh you know they're gonna give them a
path of citizenship the interesting
thing is that when you see in south
texas how the hispanic area is actually
voter republican
i know we've done an incredible job of
flicking flipping the rio grande valley
for the first time in 36 years we have a
republican mayor
down in the rio grande valley we have a
19 year old city council member
roman garcia in kerrville texas but you
just brought up a great point and this
you know i'm not really smart the army
teaches you to carry three by five cars
well you know that is smarter back too
but i want to share this quote with you
all in with the artist the uncontested
absurdities of today
are the accepted slogans of tomorrow
they come to be accepted by degrees by
dent of constant pressure
on one side and constant retreat on the
other
until one day when they are suddenly
declared
to be the country's official ideology
you know um iron man it's brilliant it
is brilliant because i tweeted about
this today there's a video
um that i saw cassandra fairbanks
tweeted in response to some video it was
one of the most absurd things i've ever
seen
a guy takes a coffee maker and he pours
i saw that he pours lemonade in the back
he puts broccoli where the coffee's
supposed to go and he puts a
salmon fillet in the coffee uh uh
pitcher or whatever
and then he he turns it on he says this
is totally legit
the lemonade will steam the broccoli and
then cook the salmon
in seven minutes the video is absurd
absolutely absurd
there's other videos where a woman is
pouring nachos all over her counter and
it's a disgusting mess
she does the same thing with spaghetti
there's videos where people throw
burgers and fries in the blender and
then and then freeze it
and make patties out of it it is
nonsense content
meant to shock people to get shares you
see the guy
pouring lemonade on salmon in a coffee
maker and he says sunny d and you're
like that's disgusting i need to show my
friends how disgusting this is here's a
problem
little kids they're going to see that
and they're not going to know
that it's meant to manipulate you yeah
because they're going to see a very
serious looking men
very seriously saying watch me cook
salmon this way
they're going to grow up with that and
then when they're older they're going to
be steam
taking a steam iron and ironing their
eggo waffle while filming themselves
with an animal face filter and it'll
just become it'll be pure insanity
because they you know we're older we
understand you don't cook
it's not convenient to cook salmon in a
coffee maker that's stupid yeah
but these kids don't know that now check
this out here's where it gets a bit more
um
damning in the at the end of the 2000s
something most of you who listen to the
show have heard quite a lot but uh it
plays into this
especially with that iran quote blogs
realized that
rage was getting the most shares yes so
what they started doing was started
saying racism racism sexism racism
then they realized combining them got
them even more shares
you had kids who were 10 years old in
2008 they they're not very politically
active they go on facebook and they see
nothing but police brutality nothing but
posts about evil racism of america
and they've been living in that their
entire adult lives
now it's no surprise they believe all
this woke insanity they believe all the
psychotic garbage because it's been
their entire life
of people just posting manipulative
content so to go to that quote
those absurdities have become the
slogans of these young people who are
now in their 20s
and voting in i love it we actually have
some of these left to sit here and tell
us joe biden is the right path towards
avoiding corruption and i'm like you
don't know anything about
about the obama administration at all do
you no the national defense
authorization act indefinite detention
provisions
how about biden inc putting his brother
in charge of iraqi construction also in
the family's making millions of dollars
the barisma deals the investigation all
china oh flying on the plane i mean come
on
i said this before i'll say it again and
then we'll segue to what i wanted to
talk about before i got derailed
if the republicans win the house back
they should impeach joe biden on
all of the evidence pertaining but they
won't do that of course they will they
will not do that be
because they believe that we're
gentlemanly we're above that
because this is a dog fight this this is
beyond the knife fight
and you know i had a dear friend of mine
a marine retired firsthand by the name
of jim reifinger
he said if you ever find yourself in a
fair fight it's all because your tactics
suck
and and we continue to want to have this
this fair fight we continue to want to
there's a great scene uh from officer
and the gentleman when david caruso is
standing there in front of louis gossett
jr
and they're going to start doing the
training on hand-to-hand combat and he's
going to use david caruso the cadet
as his example and you know dave caruso
well this cadet knows
by regulation uh drill sergeant you're
not allowed to strike me or anything
like
really and lou gossip puts it down into
a chokehold
yeah and that's what republicans are
republicans stand there
and if you resolute's rules for radicals
you know one of the rules are
to constrain your enemy into their own
principles and values
and and so that comes back to what is
happening at the border
you have a federal government that is
completely abdicated as constitutional
duty to protect the sovereignty
of the state of texas and the united
states of america and we're sitting
around talking about well we really
can't do anything about it because we
don't have
the ability of the state the
constitution says that you can protect
yourself
when the federal government abdicates
their duty this is interesting because
the way you're describing it it sounds
very much like the old trope of the
revolutionary war
the crown was very much looking for a
regimented battle on the uh
you know on the on the standard we
didn't play that way we
we didn't play and you know last it's f
i was watching last last the mohicans
that's why i was loving it
i was loving your little uh flatlock
pistol and and you're right
i mean you know we were the original
gorilla warriors
here in north america we wanted to win
we want to win it was because
you know i i i was talking to some
occupy activists
uh back in the day and they were talking
they were talking about something
a hammer brother was but i said do you
think that
the ninja warrior would walk to the
front gate and then
challenge challenge the war hello your
imperial guards
i must defeat you then i can go into the
feudal lord's
room no they snuck around back yeah they
set traps
they threw what were they called stars
they're called
they would they would go in the dead of
night and they would put wooden posts
in lakes so that when they after they
assassinated a feudal lord they would
run
on the posts on the water and people
would think they were walking on water
they wanted to create this illusion it
was all pre-planned they did not fight
by the rules
i watched this amazing fight on youtube
a long time ago of a samurai versus a
ninja
and it was incredible because in the
samurai is fighting with honor and he's
swinging and he's regimented and then
the ninja pulls
powder like chalk out of his you know
out of his
kimono or whatever it's called and
throws it in the guy's face and he was
like they don't care
about your rules or your honor they want
to win because in the end whoever wins
is the one who's going to walk away and
control things so that's the problem
with republicans
they look at everything like oh you know
we believe in the free speech of the
left and their right to speak and we'll
defend it
and they go thank you so much banham
well you know the nes
that's one of the issues that we had
down in texas
was uh you know we have control of the
texas state house 83 to 67
and we have the speaker there and i
wrote a little piece
that said please do not give democrats
committee chair positions and guess what
they ended up doing
they gave democrats 15 committee chair
positions the same democrats to guess
where they are now
they're up here in washington d.c
blocking election integrity again
after flying private jets uh you know up
here i think you've got
um matt gates lauren bobert marjorie
taylor green
they're fighters they're feisty and then
you got you know ted cruz is pretty good
holly's pretty good
and rand paul's pretty good but in terms
of feistyness
you got very very few if any republicans
but i'll tell you this democrats
man they literally defended rioters who
burned down buildings
and tried to bail out the people you
have a rioter that resulted in the death
of someone that
is a member of congress
cory bush she led the violent riot uh
that ended up with the death of david
doran the picture that you have down in
your basement
but she also led the the riot against
patty mark mccloskey
and now she's sitting on the house
judiciary committee now
but yet if you are a republican and you
say something that the democrats don't
like what does nancy pelosi do
strips you of your committee assignment
what does kevin mccarthy do well
that's the problem agree agree and they
and look there's good and there's bad
here because
when steve king came out and said some
you know something about white
nationalism on twitter in a positive
light the republicans had no problem
saying we don't want none of that yeah
if you get out of here that's right and
wrong
right but but what we have to also do is
look at the other side and say
really maxine waters can stand up
and encourage people to commit acts of
violence
against republicans or members of this
administration during a criminal trial
in minnesota
yes and say we're going to do more
unless we get what we want
yeah i mean that that is shocking that
nothing happens it's like um
it's like civil disobedience but it's a
little different
like i mean telling people to sit on a
road and block traffic you could say
that that's violent because you're
you're impeding and disrupting people's
daily lives so that's a form of violence
no
telling people to burn buildings is
different i'm filing people to
revolt against the system peacefully
well violence is causing harm to someone
or something
or not gerald nadler who's the chairman
of the house judiciary committee
when he was asked about antifa he said
it's just a myth
really so in other words you're you're
consenting you're condoning it
it's called terrorism yes when when
maxine waters showed up and said unless
we get the verdict that you know
is right we're going to be out here
we're going to we're going to push
harder we're going to do more
i mean we already we all know what
happened in minnesota the last time we
all know what happened with
like 23 plus deaths or whatever directly
associated with the riots and then some
peripheral deaths
and she says she wants more the people
of that city knew exactly what was going
to happen
they said so in interviews after the
fact i was scared these people would
show up at my house
that's terrorism that is terrorism or
you know let's let's put it out there
the only person that lost their life on
january the 6th
was shot in the back by a capitol hill
police officer
or or it was she was shot in the front
somewhere in the neck but we still don't
know who the
capitol hill police are drivers now
if that was on the left they'd be going
apoplectic right now oh yeah definitely
well let's talk about what's going on
with the border though yeah we were
talking about you
uh you said that um what the biden
administration abdicated
in terms of uh border policy
you know you have a constitutional duty
to protect the sovereignty of the united
states of america and the sovereignty of
a state
that has a 1200 mile border so when you
come in by executive order
not by legislative process which first
and foremost is unconstitutional
to say that we're going to implement an
open borders policy and just allow
illegals to flow right through
well the constitution says article 1
section 10 clause number 3 and article 4
section 4 the constitution
the founding fathers referred to it as
an invasion that's exactly what has
happened
you saw the video of me down on the rio
grande river uh
a week ago uh 2am in the morning a guy
shouts across from mexico
i've got 80 ready to cross wow some real
fearsome across we've got a few really
interesting developments one is i think
what do we have florida
sending troopers to texas yeah but see
the thing is
tim we have a national guard right in
texas
19 to 20 000 strong you mobilize your
full national guard
you put them down there to show that
this is the deterrent
you make sure that you block the
infiltration routes because what is
happening is that
we're focusing on those crossing points
where the women and children are being
funneled across
but what we saw when we were down to up
the river you could see the flickering
lights and i put on the
night vision goggles and you saw the
other folks coming across now we're
talking those are the getaways
well let's talk about one of the other
developments too there are some states
sending in
troops or national guardsmen but we have
this story but what powers do they have
it depends on what the texas is going to
allow them to do right well that's right
what i'm saying they're not allowed to
do anything because that's what i saw i
saw national guard troops
watching those people come across and
helping them out of the rafts
into texas is that well it was national
federal national guard no it's texas
national guard but we do have a story i
want to pull up yep
this is from timcast.com and for those
that are wondering this is the alpha
version of the site which is alpha
mind you but it still looks really
really cool texas sheriffs
sue biden admin for restricting ice amid
border crisis
yes so it sounds like it's it's not just
that they're not doing anything they're
act
actively hindering they are the the
attempts they are telling they have told
customs and border patrol they are
telling ice
do not do your job ice is there to
deport people
and isis being told don't do your job
don't deport people
so what are these constitutional
officers that's the interesting thing
the difference between
a sheriff and a local municipality
police officer
sheriffs are constitutional officers and
so they're standing up and saying that
you
are obstructing my duties as a
constitutional officer
because you are allowing these people or
telling these people
not to do their job and so therefore
they're bringing a lawsuit the
allegations
the allegations are scarier than just
that check this out from the article
according to the lawsuit the biden
administration's february 18th
memorandum has blocked ice officers from
taking illegal immigrants into custody
who have committed crimes like
human trafficking yeah they say quote
since the issuance of the february 18th
memorandum ice officers have been
unable to take custody of or issue
detainer requests for dangerous criminal
aliens
whose detention is mandated by the
immigration and nationality act
specifically detention is required for
aliens who have committed or been
convicted of numerous crimes other than
aggravated felonies
such as crimes of moral turpitude crimes
involving controlled substances
human trafficking money laundering and
certain firearms offenses
now that's amazing i mean sexual assault
if if biden was going to say something
like we're helping refugees go ahead and
arrest all those guys i'd be like oh
those democrats trying to find some way
this is like eh the human traffickers
let them go yeah well
that's what i saw happen you saw the
human smugglers that were the ones
pulling the rafts because at that point
in roma texas
the rio grande is about waist deep they
were pulling the rafts across
and they continued to do it until all of
those folks were faded across
tim we have had people from 160
different countries
detained now those are the ones we
detain not the ones that got away we
have people
that are on terrorist watch lists in the
in the the
del rio sector they've uh detained
people from 72 different countries
this is a national security issue that
is happening down on our border and it's
going to affect what is happening not
just in texas but
all across the united states america
we're not even talking about the
fentanyl
that is coming across wow you know what
it is it's really simple we were talking
about hr one earlier you know what
there's
there's something else in hr one we
didn't bring up and that's they want to
lower the voting age
yes why would they want to get people
with no
experience in politics or national
affairs to be voting
just what you said they they just
bombard them with the headlines
and then they go out and vote for them i
was uh covering a story a couple years
ago
during the migrant caravan crisis
and you get the standard line from the
left about refugees and things like that
and i was talking to a friend of mine
and i sent uh
actually i sent them some some documents
they blocked me
and and it was a story showing how a
family
flew from africa into brazil and they
spent
thousands it was like four thousand
dollars total to fly their family from
from africa to brazil
and then thousands more to bring them
from brazil up to the southern mexican
border
and the reason they did it was they knew
if they flew to the u.s they would be
denied
because actually going through a
checkpoint you'd get turned around but
if they came to the poorest southern
border especially at the time of a
caravan
they might get through and so i asked
them if these people were refugees
fleeing africa
brazil is amazing i've been to rio and
sao paulo
i absolutely loved rio great food
great people on the beach coconuts for a
buck super cheap why would you spend
thousands of dollars to leave a place
where you're already safe
and i'll tell you this probably because
you got bolsonaro down there who's not
playing games
and they knew that democrats would
probably give them a free pass well
look at what has happened and america is
awesome by the way america is awesome
and
so the president of mexico and the
president of guatemala
both have said and the president
guatemala said it directly to kamal
harris
you guys caused this problem the
policies were in place that kept this
under control then you come in and
change the policies
and now you have this flood so don't
come down here you know talking about
this issue you know
and and going down saying well is
climate change
that family did not leave africa because
of the weather okay
all right yeah no and you ask them they
don't say that this is
the funniest thing they say uh you know
i love that line from um
aoc when she was questioning i think
holmen was his name the yeah
and she's like legal asylees have broken
dough laws
and then he just names the laws like
actually they violated subsidy just
really dry
but these people say they're legal
asylees and they mention the climate
change thing
kamala harris like it's because of
climate change did you ask them one one
one person interviewed i think this was
by a french news outlet i think it was
afp
uh said i miss buffalo wild wings
pretty sure that ain't climate change no
that ain't nothing i got to be honest i
missed
i don't know but wild wings if you get
the really hot spicy ones you do get hot
and whatever so maybe it
this person was in mexico in the caravan
and they were interviewed vox.com vox
covered this
that they said i miss buffalo wild wings
i just busted out laughing because i'm
like
i feel you like i love me some b-dubs
but mexico city has b-dubs
yeah so what you're saying still makes
no sense but think about this also this
is all about you know
coming to seek asylum and they're living
in poverty
and you know they're being threatened by
gangs whatever
then most people out of chicago or any
of these other inner cities that
you know the left is running then they
should seek asylum somewhere too yeah no
no joke man it's not even i'm not even
playing uh on the south side of chicago
there was one kid who went to prison he
was 13. gang said
you got to shoot him or else and so he's
like he did it
and then the reason they do that is
because the kids get out when they're 18
the adults would go for life 25 to life
so they have the kids do it
yeah absolutely those kids need support
oh what's that who's running chicago and
who has been running chicago it's been
under democrat
one-party control forever but but the
problem in chicago according to
mayor lori lightfoot is the stuff that's
coming over from
indiana that's an excuse of course it is
but that's what they are
all about and we allow them to get away
with it and so this is not
you know i just been doing some reading
about remittances that have been sent
back out of the united states by illegal
immigrants
when you look at the northern triangle
countries you're talking about 36
billion dollars
a year that are going back now when you
expand that out to the top seven
countries
77 billion dollars leaving the united
states of america going back
wouldn't it be great if we just taxed
these remittances
let's just tax it at the highest income
tax rate that the democrats want so the
legal immigrants can
give their fair share what's the
remittance what is what is that exactly
this is the money that they send back
to their native countries oh so they
come here illegally they
really lose money out and they send
money out okay you know
with with no you know penalties
whatsoever and often no taxes because
it's they make money under the table
absolutely and it's a very serious
problem so when you look at places like
detroit where they've lost a lot of jobs
money
leaving an area is bad for that area
because you're taking away a trade
medium it causes all sorts of problems
especially when it's done
abruptly for people to come in they're
effectively extracting value from from
this country it's the same problem
it's a very similar problem to when we
outsource a lot of our jobs overseas
absolutely
money will be spent by you ian on a
brand new fancy watch at a local store
and that money is instantly
internationally transferred to another
country be it through the
business owner or in the instance of
this with the remittances people working
there will get paid and then send the
money
out of the country not to mention the
depression of wages
so that in the inner city communities
you know these
you know young teenagers black hispanic
they don't have the opportunity to get
these jobs because
they're going to someone that is here
illegally so it is a vicious cycle that
we're creating in our country i feel
like we got to
define the word refugee right now
because if someone's
really fleeing uh terror then i think
we have a duty to to house them at the
very least but if someone's mean to you
it says mean words that you're not a
victim well they're coached
they're coached what to say and if you
you follow the money trail there are a
lot of leftist lawyers that are going
into these countries and they're giving
them the talking points
and the the interesting thing guys is
that
they will go and surrender to the they
know who the federal border patrol agent
is that's who they surrender to
they're not going to surrender to local
law enforcement because they know local
law enforcement will detain them arrest
them what have you
and so they they know how to game this
entire system it's just like when you're
in a combat zone you tell the enemy
here's my rules of engagement this is
what i can and can't do
and then guess what they do they
understand the gap so i wish they
exploited
the same thing's happening here you saw
the story when um the blind
administration was smuggling
children into other states in the dead
of night story
yeah that is
very simply put the biden administration
engaging in human trafficking
they are and and to the point where the
cartels this this number is going to
blow your socks off
the cartels are making on average 25
million dollars a week
wow holy cow and i saw the the little
wristbands
each one of the cartels has a different
wristband because they're the ones that
are allowing you transit
through their respective territories and
you know the
adults the kids they all have the
wristband from the cartel that is
bringing them across
and even though they're not able to pay
this money guess what when they get on
this side they have cartel operatives
they're going to be working for the
cartels and sending that money back
if we are serious about this we start we
must declare the cartels criminal and
terrorist organizations
and then we go after their founding
families and resourcing i just got to
make sure i pull this up because this is
a bold thing to say but
yes it is true a video was released
showing biden admin secretly flying
migrant children into tennessee
while republican rep urges congress to
pull kamala's travel funds until she
visits the border so this is a story
from may
and it wasn't just tennessee now you
gotta understand when you are
secretly and in violation of the law
taking humans and transporting them you
are
smuggling people literally that's that's
human smuggling operations
trafficking human trafficking so the
body administration is
is engaged in human trafficking the body
administration is creating the largest
economic boom
for the criminal and terrorist cartels
how what would you do like as governor
of texas
what can you do with the federal
government
acting as the way it is like what what
are some i i
you you look at the 10th amendment and
you assert your power as a sovereign
state
you look at those two uh clauses that i
just mentioned in the constitution you
have a full mobilization
your national guard you start to tax the
remittances that are coming out of texas
you know with illegal immigrants and
that's how you build a border
uh security fund you also designate
those cartels as criminal and terrorist
organizations
so you go after their the the banks that
are you know funneling and laundering
their money you go after these stash
houses you go out to real estate agents
and agencies
and the banks that are supporting these
stash houses this is this
is an intricate system that you've got
to peel the layers of the onion back but
the most important thing you've got to
go after was resources and the other
thing is
you got to stop with the magnets if you
come into texas you're not getting free
taxpayer benefits in texas you're not
getting in-state tuition as illegal in
texas
and so it's those type of things that we
have to use as a physical deterrent
and then also economic deterrence what
kind of resistance would you foresee
from the federal government
uh the federal government just and see
that's a great point
because see that comes back to exactly
what we said republicans always put
themselves in a box that says well
we've got to get the permission from the
federal government it was free and
independent states that created
the federal government and so when you
understand federalism
when you understand your duty as as a
sovereign state
you don't sit back and you wait for the
mother may i from the federal government
you have a duty and responsibility as a
governor to protect the citizens in your
state
and right now the citizens of the state
of texas are not being protected i know
everyone's saying well we're going to
build a wall
there's 1200 miles that we share with a
foreign nation
there's only 145 miles of wall that's
been built
how long do you think it's going to take
us to build another 1055 miles
of a border wall which the trump
administration estimated
at 10 to 12 billion dollars and we've
only said that we're going to
allocate 250 million well to be fair i
heard a story that trump
actually proposed uh moats full of
alligators
that was actually reported
clearly trump no the headline exactly
exactly they said
somebody somewhere made a claim that
trump wanted moats full of alligators
and that's actually more expensive
digging a trench and filling with water
and alligators plus the rio grande is
already there it's already there
i mean you already have a physical you
know
barrier a border a river but if you're
not putting
anyone down there as a physical
deterrent
then it's just a crossing point and so
you get to watch as you know on our
website the video
of guys just fearing people across these
these videos are crazy
i've you watched someone we've had a lot
of reporters we've had on this show have
been down there
and it's the most insane thing to see a
residential neighborhood and then also
you'll see 15 dudes just
run full speed and then like border
guards chasing after them
high-speed car chases uh carjackings
have have increased
uh ransacking of grocery stores and
convenience stores these are the type of
these aren't asylum seekers what uh uh
i believe this is i'm getting this right
but um do you know the most dangerous
cities in mexico and where they are
it's right along the border yep just
south of the us border you have right
now going on
and this is going to explode pretty soon
there is a cartel
internal turf battle turf war and these
guys are gearing up
because there are certain cartels that
want to expand the drug trade fentanyl
and what have you
there are certain cartels that are only
in the human and sex
uh trafficking and there are certain
cartels that want to bring all that
together under their control
there are some incredible videos that
show some of the massacres and so how
some of these bodies
are just laying out in the streets all
over the place you can go down and you
can be on
our side of the board you can hear the
gunshots it reminds me
iraq afghanistan you can see the flashes
this is what's happening just on the
other side
and i guarantee you if they are having
an internal border
uh fight wow between the cartels on the
south side of the border
that's going to spell over to our south
border and there there are people who
have houses just like right there right
there right down the border they live in
terror every day
i mean think about this ian if you know
that a cartel member is going to come up
to you and say
if you say something we'll kill you
my first i thought would be to move my
first thought would be something
where are you going to go yeah who's
going to buy your house i don't know
i mean that would be my that would be my
my life's goal at that point would be
first
head down don't say anything that gets
me killed and then second i guess
this is america and and just imagine
okay this is no different from isis and
the taliban operating
and we're allowing them free reign and
free control of our border control how
do we stop it well hold on what do you
think would happen
if one of these guys in these houses
took a weapon saw one of these cartel
members and fired on him
killed him what do you think would
happen oh you know what's going to
happen was he armed
was an unarmed person how do you know he
was a cartel member what have you
and that's why i said we have got to uh
designate them
as a criminal and terrorist organization
and if you are working with the cartels
that's a failing offense you're going to
jail you ain't going to see daylight
didn't uh what was it fast and furious
weren't they working with
obama's administration was working with
cartels to run guns
into the u.s well i mean let's be yeah
absolutely because what they wanted
and and uh brian terry the border patrol
agent lost his life
because of that gun around this game now
of course if you say fast and furious to
most millennials out there they're going
to think of vin diesel
how convenient yeah okay good job
government yeah
they wanted they wanted to track the
weapons how they were moving and
they gave weapons i i almost just don't
believe
they were that stupid let's give guns to
all these people
that'll help us stop them no that's what
they do with isis but what they really
wanted to do
was they wanted to say that we've got a
gun problem in the united states of
america
because we have straw dealers that are
selling guns not the government
we're going to try to create the straw
man and say the gun distributors and
manufacturers doing it
and then we can therefore shut down the
gun manufacturing industry
here in the united states of america but
look uh what the obama administration
did with fafsa fears was the exact same
thing the obama administration was doing
in the middle east
within syria and then also in libya i
mean the whole thing that happened in
benghazi
was because we were trying to negotiate
and get weapons back
from the folks that we had supported
islamic jihadists against gaddafi and
we're going to send those weapons
into uh into syria yeah the u.s has a
problem with kind of doing that you know
mujahideen for instance oh yeah yeah we
we don't
have a good track record of picking
hussein's bath party we disbanded the
bath party and then they all became
al qaeda basically or was it isis i
don't remember at first it was the uh
fedeen
and then it became al qaeda in iraq
i was there and then isis isis came when
you create a void much the same as we
are doing now in afghanistan
if you create a void basic law of
physics someone's going to fill that
void
and so if you had just left a residual
force kind of like a strike force to
keep the other side at bay not worrying
about
democratic institutions or what have you
and so isis came in
uh and we knew about it as a matter of
fact uh al baghdadi was once in our
custody there and he was released
and was that under obama yes amazing
yeah it seems like obama didn't really
have the uh desire to end isis
uh he didn't have the desire to do
anything yeah and joe biden is stepping
in and doing the exact same thing
and so you're going to see an incredible
bloodbath in afghanistan just as you saw
in iraq just the same as you saw in
vietnam remember the killing fields of
pole pot
oh yeah okay exact same thing is going
to happen i've already had a couple of
my
former interpreter translators in
afghanistan ask me for letters of
recommendation so they can get out but
you know what's the interesting thing
they could probably get to the united
states of america quicker if they could
pay to go down to brazil
and come up you know through our poorer
southern border than to try to go to the
embassy and get them to do the right
thing for these young men and young
women who helped us
as interpreters and translators and
getting them out of afghanistan
they are truly under attack and they
will be killed
by the taliban by isis or whoever comes
back into power and guess who also is
moving into afghanistan now that we have
precipitously left
china oh oh i've heard that china has
taken over the mountain road initiative
but trump wanted to leave earlier
trump's initial deadline was may and
biden pushed it back a little bit but
see the thing is that anyone will tell
you
all you have to do is leave a small
residual force to keep the other side at
bay leave a small special forces
uh type of force that can make sure that
they'll come in and
once again reestablish the sanctuary i
think you know we had we had sean
parnell on the show and that's
ultimately
where we came to where he was saying we
can't stay there forever the united
states can't just be
sitting in this country but a small team
something to do exactly what you're
saying absolutely i mean we're not
talking about leaving a large
million-man force like we did
in germany for what 50 or 60 years but
if you leave
you know the quick strike force like i
say with the special operators
that can go and target certain key
individuals and keep the other side at
bait that's all you need
it's mistakes after mistakes you know we
shouldn't have been in there in the
first place
for a lot of reasons well you know the
thing is we had to go in initially but
what happens is that you lose focus you
become an army of occupation
instead of army that is enemy oriented
and you go in you start worrying about
building roads building institutions and
all those things
that's not what you're there for you're
supposed to find bad guys and kill bad
guys that's all that's needed
and now where are they going syria who
the bad guys no no no the you know binds
moving troops
who knows who knows i don't think he
knows
i agree and i i don't think that the
resource i don't think the the biden
administration is going to be too
focused on
helping americans i think it's it's
going to be more of what we see with
many other presidents focusing on
foreign policy and kind of disregarding
what americans need in this country
notably of course our own border
security seems to be a mess
and they're well it's just the same as
the pipeline
you know joe biden comes in and shuts
down oil and gas production in pipelines
being in alaska being keystone being at
fracking in texas but yeah he says to
vladimir putin
yeah go right ahead start stream too
absolutely we'll we'll
we'll track the sanctions on nordstrom 2
build your pipeline yeah uh
as for us in the u.s we'll shut them
down and it's remarkable because they're
putting pressure on a pipeline in
michigan that goes to canada canada is
outraged over what they're doing
absolutely
it's it's it's we're breaking contracts
with them and it's remarkable that we
had
with the the the the crisis we had in
texas with the the freezing oh
man if we can talk about that oh yeah
yeah but but you also have the colonial
pipeline hack
yes now is not the time to be hurting
american energy independence no it's not
the time to be heard in america
never is really no it's not and now it's
not the time to be talking about the
green new deal and all of these type of
things
because what happened in texas was that
26 percent of our energy distribution
plan
was in wind and solar about 23 wind 3 in
solar
and what happened when i mean we knew
this was coming 10 days out
well the wind turbines froze and the
solar panels froze over
and so all of a sudden what was supposed
to be 26 of your energy distribution
plan dropped down to 3 percent
and there was no backup because no one
had done any winterization checks on a
lot of the natural gas plants and we
shut down a lot of the coal fire plants
which we can look at clean coal uh to to
be burned out there
that that was the big failure was they
didn't do winterization they didn't do
the winterization no
preventative mexico maintenance checks
and services and you know what my bet is
just my opinion i haven't looked into it
but i'm willing about climate change the
people who are building that uh
those wind turbines were probably like
we don't need to worry about freezing
this is texas
climate never changes well we're good
yeah well and the other thing is that we
heavily subsidize yeah those those
systems
and uh look in the free market system if
you want to be a reliable energy source
stand up on your own
yeah you know i'm a big fan of wind
solar but we don't have the
technological um
we don't have the efficiency for one not
yet to go as big as they're going now
some countries have gone really really
big with wind
but people don't understand is that you
have to subsidize a lot of it
um or you have to get energy elsewhere
because there's not always wind
you know i mean and the challenge is
batteries transportation
and so it's it's not so simple and one
of the things um there was somebody who
posted this on facebook they were like
the uh they said something ridiculous
like the reason we won't get of the
reason we're not getting rid of fossil
fuels is because
the democrats and the republicans are
beholden to massive corporations
and they should want to make money and i
responded with the real reason we're not
getting rid of fossil fuels is that the
energy return on energy invested for
everything else except for nuclear
doesn't provide enough energy
the amount of energy going into these
systems that are like that's not
petroleum
save nuclear isn't enough and the other
thing is that even with the
the green systems the the wind and the
solar guess what you use to push it
through the system
natural gas and you know it's you know
people really don't understand
how much petroleum is used to pro
to build solar and wind and also in this
and all the all the plastics
petrochemicals yeah it takes
a lot of petroleum to even build and so
the question i'm asking people is
look i love the idea of renewable
energies geothermal
tidal energy over here of tidal energy
yeah there's different ways
is reliable the tide tide comes in tide
goes out and you capture some of the
energy
the problem is how much petroleum do you
use to build those systems
and how long will it take to pay back
and offset that carbon
and will you actually produce enough in
the long run will the device last long
enough and a lot of circumstances the
answer is no
producing solar for instance not
necessarily efficient enough right now
there's a lot of cool things we've done
with mirrors on those saltwater vats to
produce steam energy there's smart
things we're doing
but it's not going to go but they're
blocking nuclear power yeah it's like
you've got a clean solution with a
massive energy return and they're like
nah not that one because you know they
don't care about the climate they care
about power
absolutely and control yep that's it
you know man let's uh uh we were talking
about the middle east and we have
another story which i find fascinating
is the mayor of miami
has asked for a us-led intervention into
cuba
did you hear this no i didn't but uh i
think the last time we tried that it was
uh something to do with uh
with pork pigs pigs
well so we got these big protests
erupting in cuba i love this one
they're yelling freedom down with
dictatorship and what does the media say
protesting you lack of covet resources
and vaccines and things like that
of course they have to spend this
because remember it was barack obama
down there
with the castros at a baseball game and
he also took a big picture in front of a
mural
of che guevara one of the most
bloodthirsty revolutionaries ever yeah
super racist wasn't he yeah
and so they can't they can't say that uh
people want freedom people want liberty
no no it's about covert they don't have
enough mass
they need more more vaccines you see
they said uh new york times said freedom
and
other anti-government slogans
but but i do think that's funny because
i think from a libertarian perspective
you get it especially an anti-communist
perspective yeah saying freedom in cuba
is anti-government and see the thing is
that just the same as we saw
in the rio grande valley in in texas
where hispanics want safety and security
they don't want defunding the police
they
they they want their principles and
values are conservative
you're going to lose just the same as
what happened in the
last election cycle the cuban community
that that hispanic community down in
south florida
the venezuelan expatriates the
cuban-esque pastries they went heavily
for donald trump guess what's going to
happen this time
they're going to go even more so in the
next election and now here's why
you're familiar with the democratic
socialists of america yes so the
democratic socialists of america
international committee tweeted out in
support of the cuban communist regime
now here's the best part it confused a
lot of people because they don't
understand the language of communists
yeah
they tweeted dsa stands with the cuban
people and their revolution
in this moment of unrest and the
blockade
what you need to understand about the
communists is that they call their
government the revolution for instance
when i was in venezuela
they said tim poole was sent here to
destabilize the revolution
they call their communist government the
revolution so when they tweet this out
saying they stand with the people and
their revolution
what did the president of cuba just say
he said he was calling on the
revolutionary citizenry to fight back
against
the the protesters this is the
democratic socialists of america
international committee
with a pinned tweet saying they support
the communist regime here's the best
part
aoc as most of you know is a
card-carrying member of the democratic
socialists of america
a lot of people are pointing out that
bernie aoc the squad aren't criticizing
the cuban
regime right now of course so what do
you think's going to happen you saw what
happened in that in that democrat
district in 20 in 2020
in miami it was a safe democrat district
they predicted it was going to swing you
know was it like 15 points or whatever
democrat
went hard red republican won and
everyone kind of threw up with all the
democrats throw up in their muzzle like
how did this happen
it's because these people who live in
florida know exactly what's going on in
cuba and exactly what these promises
really mean
there was one viral video from a
venezuelan couple a year or so ago
where she was like everything the dsa
aoc and bernie sanders have promised you
is exactly what they told us in
venezuela
and now we're starving our industries
are collapsing crime is skyrocketing
once the most prosperous nation in south
america now it's just
the the shell of a cell and murder
more murder than any other and how did
this start how did it start what did
one of the first things that hugo chavez
did he banned private gun ownership
oh wow oh yeah never let him always
that's where it starts
you know you can bolshevik revolution
you know in in china with chairman mao
wherever you go
and it's always interesting how the left
you know it was the
democratic people's republic of korea or
is the
democratic german uh republican things
of this nation they always try to use
that democratic word but yet
they are the progressive socialists they
are the status they are the communists
they are the marxists and we've got to
get smarter with that but think about
this also
when hamas was raining down rockets all
over israel
you had you know the members of the
squad and others in the democratic party
condemning israel and so
there go there's going to come a time
when people they're our best
advertisement i guess that's what i want
to say
and all we've got to do is voices like
you all's here and others
just continue to say this just the same
as they have that constant pressure
instead of the constant retreat on our
side we have to match it with the
constant pressure of the truth that's
what i'm talking about that's why i say
free the code a lot i'm trying to create
new memes because being like no they're
wrong
is just going to empower them and that's
what republicans do all the time instead
of republicans saying here's what we
want and why they say no to democrats
yeah michael mouse brought this up he
said you've got democrats
that are saying we want universal health
care we want you
to give to us and the republicans say no
where's the republican to come out and
say i want to repeal
the the nfa or repeal some of these gun
laws or to
to say we want a law that does acts for
us on gun rights
typically they're resisting democrats
offense
always on the defense that's you know i
give you a great example and i was
sharing this with some folks at
cpac yesterday remember the the olympic
hammer thrower
who came out she turned her back on the
national average
yeah wouldn't it be great if someone
just came out and put
a little meme just a side by side
comparison
of jesse owens in 1936
standing on that pedestal after winning
the gold medal and saluting
while the national anthem was being
played munich germany 1936 you know who
was the chancellor of germany right then
oh yeah adolf hitler
and then just at the bottom says who's
the real hero
and see that's how we deconstruct
everything that they said
just like right now with this mandatory
vaccinations
let's just take their language and say
my body my choice
people have been doing that i love it
yeah candace owens tweeted something
about how her family has decided you
know what's best for them and people
called her
her pro-choice and i i just look at this
and i'm like
here's what happens you get these young
people they have no political experience
they see some older person say here's
how you respond to it but it's
nonsensical
the left either is lying or
doesn't understand that conservatives
argument is
there are two people involved in in one
body with when it comes to pro-life yeah
and if canada someone says my individual
family member made a choice
she's not deciding for another life it's
like they don't they don't understand
anything that conservatives say and it's
probably because they are just
in this isolated bubble they don't they
don't talk they're in the box
echo echo chamber right they're in their
own echo chamber
and and that's why it's so important to
understand that when they start to yell
and scream at you
when they're starting to call you the
names instead of retreating
remember what iran said the constant
retreat you've got to
you know more constant pressure because
you're winning the debate
you have taken them past their initial
little talking point which is an inch
deep
and you need to go on the offense but
too often what we do is when they call
us the name we go on the defense
which emboldens them and gives them the
power and we see power and we seed that
over to them
but we have got to be more aggressive
and continue to pound them
with the truth yeah that's why the
critical race theory stuff is really
effective
it's funny i mean we're talking about
the stuff in schools christopher ruffo's
been leading this charge jamel
james lindsay as well and they start
screaming no one's teaching critical
race there you get john leguizamo coming
out being like yo
this is just a legal talky talk or
whatever
and it's funny because someone i saw
someone on twitter point out
if you've got a problem with us calling
everything critical race theory it's no
different from you calling everything
white supremacy so welcome to the same
game you've been playing
absolutely and they hate it but you know
what is interesting that completely
debunks what they're saying is that
when the head of the american federation
of teachers randy weingarten
stands up and says we are going to teach
critical race theory
and we are going to go after parents who
try to
you know stand up against us so in other
words what the teachers unions
the left has decided is there have
initiated a war on parents now remember
the war on women
why don't we come out and say there's a
war on parents there was
a war on parents trying to make sure
that their kids
are getting a good education and not an
indoctrination especially in your urban
you know school districts where kids
aren't reading at level
kids aren't doing math at level but what
do they want they want to teach them
that
well ian
lid see i'm going so lydia lydia yeah
ian lydia and tim you're oppressing me
oh i'm not
yeah you are no i'm actually never stop
alex no no no no no you're not your skin
skin's white man nope nope so so
no you're oppressing me no you're not
serving no no you're trying to put it on
me no you're impressing me well you
can't you're
i'm a victim
that's how i see it but that's what
critical race theory is saying to me
absolutely but now i'm now you're
telling me i'm a vic now i'm a victim of
you telling me i'm i'm
oppressing you now i'm the victim no no
never ends it's a cycle no no no in
critical races
you're stuck in it oh no critical race
theory it's actually fairly simple
you as a conservative instantly become a
white supremacist
now as for me and that's true and and
also joe biden said that since i didn't
vote for him i'm not black so guess what
i did i am screwed
i'm just like you guys now check this
out though i'm just as white as lydia
the reality is for both of us if we
agree with them
then we're both oppressed if we disagree
with them
then we're both racists and our
backgrounds don't matter or anything
like that but do you understand how
confusing that is so just teach your
kids math
and reading and stop screwing around
with their minds and trying to
indoctrinate them but
the great thing tim is that when you
talk about this critical race theory
two years ago no one knew who their
school board member was yeah no one went
to school board meetings no one even
cared
who is that but now i'm saying you've
got parents showing up you got parents
fighting and pushing back i mean
you had that story up the about the uh
the parent
that the uh a four-year request oh we
got we actually yeah i pulled this up
so we've got this from the daily signal
mom says school board
threatened to sue her for seeking public
information on critical race theory in
curriculum
the craziest thing about it is she found
out because in their meeting minute
like their their itinerary it says
discussion action
filing lawsuit against nicole solis to
challenge
filing over 160 apra requests
this is a mom who said i just want
documents on the curriculum to see if
you're teaching kids critical race
theory
and then before she gets any
notification they're discussing filing a
lawsuit against her over this what are
they hiding
and see this is the mom that in 2020
they went after the suburban soccer mom
orange man bad
whatever but now because of their
overreach they just made that mom an
activist
and they just made that mom engaged in
the political process and that is going
to be the difference
as we go forward it really and lydia and
i were talking about this driving up
here
too often people have just focused on
the federal government i i know who my
congressman my senator
i'm voting for president nothing else
now people starting to realize
the school board and the city council
that level
of governance that touches you the most
tip o'neill said all politics are local
now people are getting engaged
and that is scaring the bejesus out of
the left and you know you know what i
think a lot of people are
realizing too how important their
governors are a lot of people didn't pay
attention to this
and so we were talking about well i hope
they pay attention to the race that i'm
in
oh that's the point right so we were i
remember we were talking to we're
talking about
ron desantis and maybe a trump desantis
ticket
and the fear from some of these people
in florida is like
but if you take away ron desantis from
florida
and he enters a presidency that doesn't
control the the
congress or the courts then you end up
de-powering us because he is an
effective governor in florida and that's
what people are starting to realize
is that the states are the most
important entity
and then from the states it goes down to
those the county commissions
to the city councils to the school
boards and that's where republicans have
not done a real good job
of focusing on previously and that has
been a big turn that we saw
in the state of texas we won back a lot
of school board seats
we won back a lot of city council seats
because we got people engaged we got
people focusing on that in our municipal
level elections
uh this past may you know you got to
understand though how
uh i think these people are evil because
what they're doing is
these critical race theorists they want
to bring what we call
critical race applied principles or crap
into these schools
and they will move from blue cities
democrat cities into rural areas into
red areas
run for the board with no political
affiliation and then once they're in
indoctrinate the kids yes so we're
seeing this in west virginia
in areas that are deep red you got maga
flags trump flags there are flags that
say
f biden everywhere but for some reason
the schools are adamant about critical
race applied principles
being taught to these kids and it's
because many of the parents weren't
paying attention
they already know they are now and you
were seeing these videos of the moms
showing up at this meeting screaming
there was a one really viral video of
that that black man saying his kids are
being told they can't succeed
think about how insidious and nefarious
it is to tell that man's children they
can't succeed
that's how you're you're trying to make
the next generation of victims
and that's what progressive socialism
has to have
they i mean if you're a victor why do
you need them okay why do you need the
the handout why do you need to be told
to stay at home and we'll send you a
check
you know i want to get out and i want to
work for myself and that's
that's the corruption that's the the
undermining of the fabric of america
that we see
and that is really the liberty and
freedom that you're talking about ian
the ability to go out with your own mind
and do for yourself
but when they take that away then all of
a sudden you have these young people
like you're saying that america sucks
america is horrible america's bad
the biggest institutionalization
happened over the past year
when they locked everybody down
everybody down shut down the businesses
and then put them on government payments
and now these people are stuck in it you
can't just cancel it
they become institutionalized yep so how
are you gonna you're getting 16
an hour on average from these payments
you can't be evicted
why are you going to go find a job
somewhere that pays 60 an hour for free
and that's how they back in went into a
living wage
that's right they couldn't get it
through a legislative process so what
did they do they put people out of work
they back-ended it and they they went
and destroyed and decimated the mom
pastors all the small businesses
and now they are dependent upon the
government but i think
the the it's it's it's an exploitation
of the weakness of many of these people
and the circumstances many people find
themselves in mostly in cities
of course out here we've been growing a
lot of our own food
it's a rugged individualism once you get
outside the city right
uh but even myself growing up in the
inner city of atlanta
we had our own garden and you know got
back there with my dad and we worked the
garden
we grew our own food and whatever but
how many how much of that do you see
today
but people need to thank you exactly
when the government comes and says now
you're dependent
upon us you can say i'll grow my own
food it kind of started off like
as americans we were all kind of
decentralized we had our state we had
our local farms we worked
locally and then it slowly started to
federalize over the 1800s it became more
and more centralized and now with the
internet
it's shattering and decentralizing again
because you can see like a guy a local
guy farming makes a youtube
channel has a 1.6 million followers and
people start emulating his local
behavior locally
and you see like ron desantis is a super
famous guy
who's a governor who like 20 or 30 years
ago you might not even know his name
ah but now what are they doing you have
the facebook you have the twitters and
the youtubes that are
going out and saying yeah that content
we're going to censor yeah
and it's pressure like the iran quote
that's why i explained to people
they're not outright banning us they're
slowly
slowly banning channels they they've
given stephen crowder several strikes
they're really close trying to get get
getting rid of him and one of the
strikes crowder got was for quoting cdc
data they don't care
now for us we get the applied pressure
that's where
people mention hey i don't get
notifications for your videos anymore
it's weird that somebody would come and
watch this show every day we do it at
8pm
and then youtube would think they don't
like here's the youtube's argument is
if people don't click the notifications
and don't engage in the content
we're not going to notify them anymore
even if they ask for the notifications
then how is it we have people saying i
watch a show every day
i'm not getting notifications anymore or
i was unscribed unsubscribed from your
channel
these are the things that people have
been feeling for some time and it's the
pressure they put on you
because here's here's what they want
they isolate the audience that can watch
a show like this
so that over time we don't get new
viewers but we slowly
slowly lose viewers unless we lead you
out
right however i think we've been doing a
particularly good job i think crowder
has we are growing regardless that's why
i say
sharing this video and sharing the
videos of the creators you like
shuts down that attempt to put obstacles
in our way they are they're going to
give as many advantages as possible to
all of the left channels
these these podcasts appear on the front
page you've never used a computer before
you open it up you turn on youtube boom
there's a left wing mainstream
establishment podcast
for stuff like this anti-establishment
or right-wing content
nah it's not gonna happen they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna push you
down
they're gonna hide you from from the
main algorithm you're not gonna see
what's happening
but incident understanding again lydia
and i we had great conversation driving
up from uh
reagan airport this is the 1984
this is the brave new world that we're
living in and
you know young people i just got to ask
why do you want to hang out with control
freaks
i mean if you're on a college campus why
you want to hang out with the people
that are going to tell you what you can
see what you can eat what you can wear
what you can drive
you know all of this stuff i thought you
know me being a dad now grandpa
you know my daughters always say leave
me alone let me do my own thing
but now you've got you know big
government coming in and telling you
exactly everything
you know flying up here and we were
discussing this
i am sick and tired of hearing the
constant drone in the airport
the tsa the law says that you must wear
a mask in in the airport not failing to
wear a mask will result in the fine or
criminal penalties
and i'm thinking say what law
there's never been a law i think thomas
massey tweeted this
he never voted on that that's what i
said there's never been a law and what
is the law i mean i remember schoolhouse
rock and it kind of taught you
how you get to become you serve as a
bill and then you become a law
there was never a law that says that we
have to wear a mask in
airports or or you know wherever but see
when you are constantly
droning people with this messaging and
what you see out there in the public
space
then all of a sudden people become the
mindless lemmings and they just accept
it much the same as you saw in 1984 and
so
i would say to everybody that's out
there the next time you're in an airport
or someplace
and someone says that you know you have
to follow this law
ask the person what show me the law when
was it
when was it passed when was it signed
because it was not and so
we are moving away from being a
constitutional republican to be in a
constitutional monarchy
where someone's just sitting back and
signing stuff it's it's it's not even
necessarily a monarchy it's something
it's despotism it's it's yes you you've
you saw it with these governors it's
totalitarian yeah it was remarkable uh
cuomo he killed 15 000 people yeah and
nothing happens
yeah he's gonna get away with it he got
away with it as far as i can tell right
yeah he will
that's horrifying that really really or
he was warning
everyone else he was warned that if he
put sick people in these nursing homes
they he would kill them
and he had the mercy vessel he had the
jabbet center and he
used it killed the people instead and
and that's it
he gets away with it the only scandal
that erupts okay so that was a bit of a
scandal but then
oh no he inappropriately talked to women
and touched them i mean that's bad for
sure but wow
he can kill 15 000 people and the
media's more concerned that he was
inappropriate with women yeah he did the
bill curling
you know babies
it's uh i'll tell you one thing watching
some of these stories about schools and
the indoctrination of children
i'm mixed in my pessimism and optimism
i'm optimistic steve bannon said
something that when these mothers
see what their kids are being taught
there's going to be a major revolt and
it's going to cause massive change
and i think he's right i think
absolutely i think when a little kid
comes home and tells their mom they're
evil and they hate them the mom's gonna
be
like what happened to my baby like
they're not gonna stand for that
but i'll tell you what makes me really
optimistic is what you're talking about
with the states
the power the states have and we've seen
it ron desantis
hitting it out of the park texas is
doing pretty good pretty good
i think maybe maybe when you're uh when
you're in there yeah i mean we lost some
10
000 small businesses and and really you
know
ron desantis is the gold standard right
now yeah and
you know there are a lot of things look
our border we should not be sitting
around
asking for a mother may i from the
federal government we should be doing
everything possible to protect and
secure our borders i want to follow up
on that a little if you were going to
establish the national guard like to
protect the border how would that
work long term would they stay there for
long periods of time
they stay there until we get this thing
under control they stay there until we
have
you know driven the cartel uh into to be
irrelevant uh they stay there until we
make sure that we get that situation
because you got to stem the flow
and then you have the ability to you
know start the deportations start
arresting people start getting them out
of the state but you got to stem the
flow and no one is stemming the flow
right now
would it be like building facilities for
them to live at on the border
and then you just line up like basically
bases national guard bases well i mean
you can set up some temporary type of
housing but the bottom line is that you
get biometric data and you say have a
great day and
go back across the the rio grande river
i mean
you're not coming into texas to hang out
okay you you come across and that's the
deterrent
that that's the deterrent that was there
the remain in mexico policy of president
trump
that the body administration flipped and
i think it's section 42
which is the you know the covet uh
emergency uh
uh order that uh president trump put in
place if they lift that
then katie bar the door there's even
more people that's gonna come across
i think it's it's remarkable that taking
control of your borders
is racist according to democrats well
you know like i said i ain't really
black
i'm so right but again but then again
you know tim that's what i'm saying
i'm not responding right to those
interests just do it
right and that's the problem of
republicans because they put themselves
in the box in the in the corner uh that
the left is trying to create for them
it's just saying you know i i'm tired of
your name calling we're going to do
what's right by the rule of law
absolutely let's take super chats for
those that have not already give that
like button a little tap subscribe to
this channel
share the show with your friends if
you're on itunes spotify whatever share
the podcast
and uh check out timcast.com we're going
to have a spicy bonus
segment or members-only podcast episode
it'll go up tonight around 11 or so p.m
and we'll be talking about um i can't
give you the full name i'll just call it
the rainbow bleep monkey because youtube
is a little too spicy for youtube but
this is serious stuff
what they're doing to children and it's
not just in america so we'll talk about
that many of you may be familiar with
the story but we're going to get into
that one but let's read some super chats
james cood said newtoncast.com member
full-time soldier in the texas national
guard come visit our great state tim and
friends
i would love to yeah but you know we
were we were looking at a bunch of
states
before we settled on here my fear with
texas is all the people from california
and arizona they're coming they're
coming in they're going to start voting
two types of people as we talked about i
think uh before we went
on camera they're the folks that are
leaving california illinois new york
new york and new jersey that are sick
and tired of those places they're
conservatives and they
want to be in a place like texas for the
right principles and values but then
when you transport those large
employment bases
and you see where they're settling in
they're settling in in north texas
they're settling in down there in
houston harris county
that's the concern all of the major
urban population centers in texas
dallas austin houston san antonio
el paso or controlled by the left and
that's the playbook of the left is to
come in and take over the urban
population centers where you see the
largest amount of crime
and all of these things we have got to
get into those urban
population centers and exactly what
we've done engaging with the hispanic
community
engaged with the black community they're
conservative in nature we've just got to
remind them of that
all right we got zachary birdy says
lieutenant colonel west texas voter here
governor abbott has made it clear that
marijuana decriminalization is off the
table while he is in office
how do you view the issue of marijuana
legalization i support
medical marijuana but as far as
legalizing uh
marijuana look i'm probably not the guy
to talk to about that i've never smoked
never drank in my life definitely never
taken drugs
and i don't want to see that become a
gateway to something even greater and
when you look at some of these other
states that have legalized marijuana
such as in colorado they have some other
issues i know they were once saying that
that's a great boom for the economy
but even 60 minutes said that it has not
gone very well as far as the marijuana
growth why
because the government comes in and they
institute regulations okay
you know what it has done though it's
it's it's hindered the cartels very much
so
it makes it really hard for them to
compete when you've got colorado with
all
their bagels yeah but they're shipped
into fentanyl and and so remember
avocados actually no joke well i'm not a
big
guacamole guy but but but if you look at
what just recently happened i think
about a month and a half ago
here in washington dc one of the largest
fentanyl busts was right here in
washington d.c
enough fentanyl to kill 21 million
americans
sinaloa cartel now where's the center
lower cartel operating
across from across from texas so that
shows you how that affects you
i get with medical marijuana i get
concerned with red flag laws
so if someone goes in and they're like i
have a elbow injury and they get medical
marijuana that's cool but when they go i
have stress
and then they get medical marijuana then
they get put on a list well you've got
to be very careful i've got some very
dear friends and their son has these
epileptic seizures
and you know it's been proven that that
can help assuage his uh epileptics
absolutely so those are the type of
things we have to look at but you know
going in and saying hey man i just
stumped my toe i got a hangnail
i need some you know the thc nah that's
not what i'm talking it's the cbd that's
real cbd is very non-psychoactive
absolutely
all right let's see jackson kai says tim
would you consider having robert barnes
on the show he's followed you for a long
time and said he'd
love he'd love it if you've had him on
has a lot of inside info from trump to
rittenhouse
we will uh yes absolutely we'll figure
out the schedule and we will look into
robert barnes
i recently watched an episode of uh viva
frey and robert barnes of course i am
very familiar with who they are
all right josh l says big fan tim ian
lydia and lieutenant colonel alan west
i'm curious what mr west thinks of
military movies just watched the
tomorrow war
are there any very realistic movies
military movies you'd recommend
well i will tell you without a doubt
when you look at blackhawk down that was
very realistic
um i love you know the saving prophet
ryan i think that saving private ryan
when you saw that those opening moments
of what happened at d-day it reminded
people that bullets do hit bodies
and they hurt bodies because we kind of
got this belief uh after desert shield
desert storm 30 years ago that was kind
of like you know video games what have
you
so those are the type of movies that uh
that i really appreciate
and uh you know like i said last night i
was watching the uh the french and
ending award lassen mohicans
yeah did you see platoon yeah i saw
platoon but you know that was kind of
over the top
you took everything that was bad about
vietnam and you put it in a two and a
half hour movie
uh and my older brother was in vietnam
were there problems of vietnam
absolutely but i think oliver stone you
know took that from a political approach
it was my model around his time too he
served in vietnam
i think that was a lot about his
personal experiences he tried to tie in
all right let's see
emirates lillium uh eramuras lillium
says for alan west
first thank you for your service second
i'm going into the air force as soon
as a geos uh force soon as a geospatial
intelligence analyst any words of advice
i will i will tell you that you know
what i saw recently from
general milley who's the chairman of
joint chiefs of staff and the chief of
naval operations also
i'm very concerned about the
politicization of our military
that we're starting you know in the
military we take a note to the
constitution
but it is almost getting to the point
we're trying to make people take a note
to an ideology and critical race theory
should not be
uh being implemented in our united
states military you cannot have an
effective and cohesive force
if you're telling one group that they're
oppressed and the other group is an
oppressor and the other thing that
concerns me
the uh lieutenant colonel who was
relieved of command and the in the space
force because he spoke out against
marxism well marxism is the antithesis
to our constitution so we're getting to
the point where we're going to punish
commanders in the military for speaking
out against something that once upon a
time i stood on freedom's ramparts
you know to fight against the old soviet
union uh but i will tell you go into the
military honor your oath that you're
taking
and always remember that even after you
take off the uniform your oath remains
right on brandon l martin says tim have
you thought about bringing on the
average voter to the show
the well-known political pundits are
great but it would be interesting to see
average voters and hear their voices
on current events we did talk about that
for some time getting some like
regular working-class people onto the
show but actually
i think what works better is doing a
different show with regular working
people so some kind of
either one or the other or both panel
discussions where we have like a few
different people
talking you know we can ask questions
and then actually just having like an
open forum discussion
the original idea we had was to bring
the van to various parts of the country
and then do interviews with regular
people just like come up and talk to us
kind of like change my mind like crowder
does but more
just we're not going to argue with you
we're going to ask you basic like what
do you think about donald trump
get the answer what do you think about
the lockdowns get an answer
then covet happened so but we're
expanding
we're the next show we're gonna be
launching is the the the mysteries show
we have a name for it's gonna be epic
the stories are awesome
and then we've got chicken city which is
silly and very very easy to set up and
kind of just a side thing but we're
going to be doing this like regular
people
in the world kind of stuff some men in
the street stuff and we're getting that
we're also going to be doing short
documentaries
on the ground investigations we have now
i think
we have seven people working in the
newsroom so far and the site's gonna be
launching soon if you were watching
earlier we had an alpha version you
could see the site for a brief moment
there's a lot of work that has to be
done on it but it's gonna be great hey i
wanna touch on chicken city for a second
the early bird
is the rooster by the way uh he gets
he's making sure everybody gets that
worm
i think that he's screaming the rooster
in the morning because he wants to wake
people up to eat either because he wants
to get fed
or he's waking up the other animals to
go get the bugs and the worms because
it's 4 40 in the morning no no
he doesn't scream in the morning he just
screams all the time
dude he'll come up to you a foot away
from your face and look at you and then
scream full volume
that's right over and over yeah like in
the middle of the day he's not he's not
screaming because it's the morning he's
screaming because he woke up in the
morning he wakes up and he's like
oh i'm awake he just yells
it's hilarious to watch him it's it's
it's really funny how he
like um man chicken chicken uh rape
culture man oh it's bad
it's like the rooster just a dark
underbelly of chicken life
that rooster man he's not playing around
we didn't know we had a rooster we
didn't get a rooster he was it was
assigned a female at birth and then grew
up into a guy and we were like
i guess we have a rooster but we wanted
one anyway so he wasn't identifying
you know we thought it was a hen until
it started to go through you know
chicken puberty
yeah and then we called the farm and he
was like no puberty blockers
no none of that none of that no none of
that good yeah
and now now now it's it's huge she's a
big rooster big beast
he's gonna get bigger too i like that
guy he's well fed to put him mildly
they they we let them in the farm they
stole all the tomatoes they went right
for the tomatoes stole as many as they
could
it was hilarious they were like one was
running around the cherry tomato and
like chasing it
ah it's good fun it's good fun all right
let's see where we're at
the sinister sibling says i'm not
american so i don't fully understand
in my opinion having the texas democrats
essentially forfeited their positions of
power in the texas state government
yes they have and that's one of the
things that people are talking about
is that can you declare that those seats
have been vacated
and you can declare for a special
election to replace those individuals
right on all right bryant chacon says as
an american born to cuban immigrants i
spent several summers in cuba and i've
seen the poverty first hand
great to see them standing up libertad
that's right
amen all right p nilsson says as a texan
please tell lieutenant colonel alan west
thank you for using his position in
helping pass hb 19
1927 constitutional carry in texas
yeah absolutely and there's a sad thing
that uh texas is not the first state
to get constitutional carry pass it was
the 21st and and
doesn't texas have like a course to get
a handgun license or something yeah
yeah i mean and and that's one of the
things that you can still if you want to
go through their course to get
your uh concealed carry permit but that
gives you reciprocity with other states
but
if you can pass a background check i
mean that's your weapon and
the constitution is your permit so you
can carry that weapon that's what
constitutional care is all about that's
right bernie sanders has it
in vermont that's crazy yeah yeah yeah
all right
kyo katsuma says should i be worried
trying to find a based lawyer in chicago
my equity and inclusion director is
inviting us to training to talk about
how whiteness impacts us as an
organization and individuals
i don't know man probably chicago might
be hard but the chicago suburbs are
actually fairly
moderate and if you go a little bit
further out you'll find a lot of
republicans i mean illinois is almost
entirely republican except for chicago
but i would think that you know
employees have to start coming together
and filing you know class action suits
to saying you know you can
you know i'm here to work i'm here to
these are my duties and responsibilities
i'm not here for you to indoctrinate me
into a certain ideology
yeah all right let's see we got
let's see i don't actually i think
youtube would ban us if i read that one
so you know sometimes we just keep going
james says i'm glad i'm a timcast.com
supporter because youtube is going to
demonetize this video
you know surprisingly we do get they do
monetize basically
every show and then we put it up for
review and then they monetize it so
we don't we don't really rely on ads on
the youtube version of things
we started putting ads on the podcast
version of things and uh but super chats
help make this show keep it live you
know that's there's a lot of risk to
being live
yeah because we've had i think four
instances where people have said things
where it's like
youtube will ban us who would have ever
thought that we would be living in the
united states of america
where you had to be worried about your
speech your expression
your right to uh peacefully assemble or
your right to petition your government
for redress or graves it's who
i mean right i'm 60 years of age and i
would have never thought
that what i saw when i went over through
checkpoint charlie to east berlin in
1985
will be happening here i mean i just you
know the stasi and all of this stuff
is happening here the fact that you have
nancy pelosi telling the capitol hill
police
that they can go down into florida and
you know
start to go and investigate people and
that's crazy
yeah it's really weird there have been a
few super chats have said this we got
this one from js allen west must run
with trump i am highly impressed one one
person said they wished you were the vp
choice instead of pence
that would be awesome in 2016. had you
considered that
or is that just something you know what
you yeah yeah you don't
like run for vp you gotta someone has to
want you to do that
right right now the most important thing
is that we have got to get texas under
control because they are targeting texas
and if you destabilize texas
the country's gone michael ford says as
a lifelong texan i love greg abbott but
i love colonel west
it is going to be a hard-fought election
if abbott wins at least mr west will
force him farther right
yeah but the sad thing is that that
that's a politician's way
that i am just going to change my my
policies and my views and my visions
just to get reelected and if that's how
you feel about what greg adam is going
to do what does that say
about what you're voting for yup that's
right it's a good point
all right greg duvier says i became a
member last friday since you pulled your
video from youtube
i've been enjoying listening to tim and
ian uncensored
oh yeah we swear that it's not family
friendly
yeah so the this youtube version is more
of the pg-13
get ready for this oh we don't we don't
bleep in the members only oh
no it's locked youtube is the more pg-13
okay you know and plus youtube's got
ridiculous
communist rules that we would get banned
instantly if we said a name
like it's ridiculous yeah so we do we
can we do it we can and the members
you know but again it just drives me
crazy that there are men
and women who have served and sacrificed
and committed and lost their lives
to defend the constitution and the
rights that you have your bill of rights
and we got these people that are just
spitting in your eye no it's crazy this
this technocrat
technocracy this technocracy that's
building technocracy rising i'm done
with it
yeah we need this we need to free the
software code disassemble power from
these things and give it back to the
people
by creating a free software social
network and it's a mobocracy too
it's terrifying i know the republic is
built to prevent against that
but these representatives also are
getting bribed so
i'm interested in taking them out of the
equation if we can and
you know what do you mean voting people
out and stuff yeah instead of having
yeah one person say because the next
thing i say well ian said he want to
take people out of the equation
instead of having 430 representatives
that each person
is beholden i don't know how many
seventy thousand americans just have
these seventy thousand americans vote
yes or no on
on something it goes to a a computer the
computer will say the tally is yay or no
and then that's the referendum they do
you have 430 of those yay or no's and
then you add them together you don't
need a person to collect it and
say it for you that's going to get
bribed and lie and do what they want
well then you have to get involved in
the system to make sure that you have
someone that is participating in a
representative democracy
because the fear is that you know you
don't want a pure democracy a pure
democracy leans itself toward tyranny
now referendums that's something that
you can have at the local level case in
point
uh the austin city council very far left
leaning they came out with that homeless
camping ordinance
the people down in austin and also the
very blue city they said
you know what how many petitions how
many signatures do we need to get that
on the ballot
and guess what they overturned that uh
that homeless
campaign ordinance in austin texas yeah
ref referendums exist in not every state
but a lot of states
was that like a direct democracy you you
get enough signatures on an issue
yeah yeah and that gets added on the
ballot california those yeah
that bothers me i don't like direct
democracy because mob you're just
calling for
no i want a more direct republic so
rather than have
these these house members that are
basically fielding
the bill uh the populists could i mean
i love the national initiative for that
for that situation well
i you could allow them to steal draft
bills but maybe not vote on them
the representatives yeah i don't think
that system quite makes sense i don't
know man they're getting bribed
and that's well there's a very big
vulnerability in the system here's you
gotta understand it's not necessarily
that they're getting bribed
there was this famous moment where marco
rubio was accused of taking money from
the nra which has corrupted him and he
says no no
i think it was rubio it might have been
cruz he i think was rubio he said
yeah i don't take money from the nra
it's that the nra gives me money because
they like my views on gun rights yeah
and we take them out to launch and then
so what's really happening is not
bribery it's that the candidates you see
up top
are the ones who have the acceptable
views by the various special interest
groups
yeah right that's what we're told now
bernie sanders and trump got a lot of
donations from regular people though and
that pushed them up to the top
bernie however for very obvious reasons
is not
strong enough to break the door down
into the establishment and trump was
a little bit more than was needed to
break through the door down i mean
he walked up and just kicked it and
stormed in well
he did not need that money yeah i mean
he was able to come and uh and fuel
himself now
as opposed to a bloomberg who could have
you know fueled it but
he didn't have a message and and he was
just all over the place he was
the hypocrisy and the irony just lived
through him
it's gonna get real interesting next
year
2023 and 2024 because right now we're in
the lull
we're in the calm before the storm the
presidential election ends
everybody's a little burned out tired no
elections
no big next year's the midterms oh
republicans if they take back that house
what will they do with the power
probably not a whole lot but the
democrats are still worried about it
well remember remember what history yeah
history has shown that bill clinton his
first midterm election
lost 54 seats contracting with america
newt gingrich
barack obama lost 63 congressional seats
in his first midterm elections so
that's why it comes back to hr1 and s1
that's why they want to have all of
these things that they did in november
2020 codified into law
so they can protect themselves
absolutely right now so they can protect
themselves about what's going to come
down to pike next
november yeah all right crafter says
alan west you're a great inspiration and
i'm happy to see you on the tim cast irl
again
tim thank you for having lieutenant
colonel alan west on again hello and
thank you to ian and lydia
and all those making tim cast irl
canadian but the border is concerning
yeah people in canada are basically
locked up yeah they're locked down
yeah yeah yep that's it's creepy man
all right let's see brandon tom says
thank you sir
regarding the idea of party switching
please explain how the republicans
became the party of small government
since the civil war
i thought the union was the
industrialized populist side of the war
well i think when you talk about smaller
government what you're looking at is a
federal government that is less
intrusive they don't want to have the
bigger government policies
uh they don't want to be the creation of
the
look at the the great society programs
of lyndon johnson that uh the welfare
united states that was created that's
what they want to try to do they want to
have less regulations
and you saw that during the trump
administration where he said you know if
we're going to create a
regulation i think he's like four or
five have to fall off the books
that's real constitutional conservatism
that's what the republican party is
supposed to be about when they say
the lower taxes the smaller government
things of that nature
but again being a progressive has
nothing to do with the political party
it has everything to do with
how you see the relationship between the
individual and the institution of
government
and if you believe that the institution
of government is sovereign and supreme
over the individual
you're a progressive that's just the
bottom line progressive is just fancy
branding
fancy branding absolutely they were the
original eugenicists
yes they wanted uh only only what did
they call it they wanted specific people
to have kids and not
other people they didn't like so messed
up because progress is so
key in that and needed but that that is
how they can manipulate language because
you know why do we not you want to be
progressive i mean even we have
don't you like flow don't you want
progressive insurance
[Laughter]
all right we got greg mccormick he says
future governor west thank you for your
service my pleasure south dakota is much
like texas and florida in regards to
freedoms and leadership
however we however we lack real
leadership in the u.s senate
with john thune we need help getting him
replaced do you have any ideas
no i mean i don't know who you could
elevate up there in south dakota but
again
i think that you're going to see a real
you know seismic shift
across the united states of america and
you know once upon a time you had those
blue dog conservative democrats but the
progressive
left came in and just wiped them all out
and i think that you're going to start
to see people look in the republican
party for true
constitutional conservatives that
believe in and you know and will stand
by what they say on the campaign trail
and not like the previous guy said well
you know i'll just move a little bit
more this way
uh in order to get re-elected and then
after i'm reelected i'll go right back
to the same way
and that has been that uh what they call
it the the debating switch
that you've seen a lot from people
running on the republican side
look donald trump came in and he did
exactly what he said
and that was just amazing a person that
ran for political office
that owned up to his promises yeah i
think it's storming it it is totally
okay
it is if the power goes out we'll panic
and then plug in a bunch of batteries
yeah it'll be fine
all right oh we got i don't know if the
storm interrupted but
no i'm good all right we're good cause
this one's a good one captain says tim
you inspired me
29 inch m82a1 in flat dark earth is on
order
so we did a video where i took out my 50
bmg m82 and
you know we set it up and we fired it we
all missed but we got a glancing shot on
the steel target we were hoping the
steel target would actually just
yeah vaporize in this was the range oh
man it was pretty decent uh i'm not
sure maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah we were
we were a bit far away and it was a lot
of fun
and uh you know we we had i forgot
what's called i think it's like an rn 52
or something you know what i'm talking
about
breach loaded uh uh 50 bmg wow
yeah that hurt and i didn't i didn't
fire that one because that's th so
that's just
you you you put it in you screw in the
back and then it goes
all the force into your shoulder so luke
fired around
in front loop and the shock wave shut my
phone off because i was standing right
next to him filming
and then my phone just turns off and i
was like oh come on
so i'd they were like go behind on the
next one because you're going to hit
and it was like but with the m82 it's
it's semi-automatic
so a lot of that energy gets used for
the reload so it's not it's actually not
that bad
okay yeah yeah it was it was it was a
whole lot of fun do your favorite
weapons you've used
over the years yeah you know one of my
favorite is the m1 garand
i have uh one of those and uh i just
love going out there because you know
uh general patton said that was the
weapon that changed world war ii does
that use a clip
yeah wow it's so cool i mean you you
fire ping it pops right out and there
it's it's just an awesome weapon what
was it
that turned the tide of world war ii uh
i think it was the
ingenuity of the individual american
soldier
uh and if you think about what happened
on d-day uh
centralized control they could not
reposition the german forces without the
approval of adolf hitler
oh wow and that just uh enabled us to
maneuver and do what was necessary and
we got that foothold into normandy and
then we marched inland
across france and don't forget it was
the soviets who sent wave after wave of
their own men to their deaths that
overwhelmed the
the the nazis on the on the no stalin
front
yeah but that's that's 42. it's funny
because we make fun of the
you know futurama is that bran again
like i said wave after wave of my own
men
actually yeah the soviets were just like
cheap crap and lots of it
and they sacrificed just people they
would send people without weapons
behind the people with weapons so when
they would get killed they'd run up and
take their weapon and keep fighting
enemy at the gate
yeah about the great russian sniper
vasily zaitsev
yeah all right let's see
what do we got here it's leo says i am
23 in texas
who wants to wants desperately to make
things happen that will defend our
freedom the problem is i have no idea
where to start
mr west what do you advise as a fellow
texan do i run for office
yeah absolutely let me tell you why uh
down in kerrville texas
19 years of age roman garcia decides to
run for city council
against a entrenched progressive
socialist
and ended up beating her by 12
percentage points and i think that it's
so important that we get our young
people instead of telling them to go and
door knock and
and phone bank and everything let's get
them into city councils let's get them
in the school board who knows better
about what's going on in our schools
than someone that recently graduated
from those schools
and so that's how you build your farm
team so i would say go out and see what
you can do there locally in your city
council school boards and get engaged
and get involved
right on all right abe eckstein says
larry elder just announced he's running
for governor in california
wow wouldn't that be amazing is that
true yes it is
larry elder california that would be
absolutely amazing
let's do it i would not want to debate
larry
yeah but i mean i mean i wouldn't want
to i'd be like yeah let me know i just
i'll take your word for it you know what
i mean like i don't need to debate him
he can give me advice
you know yeah have him run california
that'd be fantastic
yeah the problem with california is um
too big
no no no it's it's it's the exploitation
of of the ignorant
you know uh john stewart
liberal daily show said we need some
kind of draft
where people will will serve the
community for a certain amount of time
because we've lost that connection to
the community he was basically saying
service guarantees citizenship it does
but you have a lot of people right now
who have nothing they're not tied in any
way to the system so they don't care
they just want from the system i tell
you man nothing bothered me more than
seeing
friends of mine some skateboarders that
i knew posting videos of them being like
i'm doing what needs to be done and
dropping their melon ballot
and they're like we gotta stop donald
trump and i ask him like oh what did
donald trump do
well he's just bad how is he bad you
know he's like he's a fascist what does
that mean
i'm just saying man like we gotta bro if
you can't tell me
what you're talking about and you have
just stepped in
and voted for something you didn't know
i'll tell you what the problem is the
problem isn't any one man
the problem is an ignorant population
with no with no care in the world for
community
who are saying i saw something on the tv
so sure have whatever you want well the
amazing thing is that you got an
organization that calls itself antifa
which means anti-fascists but what do
they do they beat up people that have
points and insights and perspectives
different from theirs
i mean they beat up small business
owners yeah it's it's you know
they'll come back to they'll come back
out with you with the academic
definition of
fascism is authoritarian nationalism the
problem is
sure but germany was taking over other
countries
yes i'm not sure like when he was like
we're just taking the part of poland
that's ours and then we're going to
invade poland and france yeah that's
ours too
slovakia and everything else yeah it
wasn't it's
world domination yes it is so as far as
i'm concerned i just look
it's fish i'll say fascistic or
authoritarian they do the same things
but i will tell you what's interesting
is that antifa is also identitarian
they believe race should be a core
component in law well they have that in
common with hitler
well the whole social justice thing is
nothing but the forcible mandating
of equality of outcomes equity it's not
justice no it's different yeah it's
equality of opportunity it's not equity
that's someone sitting somewhere else
and saying
how do we make sure everybody's the same
social egalitarianism is not a premise
of the united states of america
here's a good one though john curry says
would alan west be willing to be trump's
chairman of the joint chiefs in 2025
well to be the chairman of joint chiefs
of staff you have to still be in the
military oh there you go could you like
everybody's just like colonel west could
they like put you back in the military
no
as a civilian you know i could be a
secretary of defense but i can't be a
chairman of joint chiefs
oh okay all right i can't read this name
because in
and they said no notifications there's
simple reason i've just discovered i got
unsubbed from three of your channels
no random youtube glitch ha ha that's
right it's always uh it's always a
glitch maybe it's a
third-party app possible oh maybe i
don't know
perhaps but uh you know it's always
funny how these glitches happen isn't it
yeah behind the scenes
yeah all right let's see we'll try and
grab a couple more here
pretty boy jeremy says question for alan
west with the concerns of school boards
shutting people down what's your
thoughts on parents duty
do they need to do more yeah the parents
need to be engaged and the parents uh
look up what happened at south lake
texas with the carroll independent
school district
before there was critical race there
there was the cultural competency action
plan
and they were trying to force this into
that school district what did they do
they came together they created the
south lake families pack
and uh normally in a municipal level
election school board whatever
if you get six percent turnout you're
pretty happy right they had 41
turnout and they went out in their
community they found good quality people
to run for school board
and the margin of victory against the
left was 40 percentage points wow
nbc news story uh and so that's what you
have to start doing at the community
level once again getting engaged
finding out who is on your school board
and finding those candidates can run
against them and support them and
resource them
and then you continue on all right so we
got two pretty important ones we got
scrogg says i cannot find his governor
donation website
texasvoter west4texas.com
westthenumber4texas.com all right
thank you mitch marco says longtime
listener member and first
donor how are i believe he's asking
how are you similar to governor abbott
and different from him and why are you
better
well i'm similar to governor abbott that
i'm a texan and i'm an american
i am different from him because i don't
believe in begging for permission from
the federal government
i believe that as a governor it's your
responsibility to protect the people
and the other thing that you will never
see me do
no elected official has the enumerated
power to decide who or what is essential
in the state of texas or anywhere in the
country the most essential thing in
america is liberty
and benjamin franklin said those who
would surrender essential liberty for
temporary security
in the end don't deserve neither liberty
or security
and we'll lose both unless right there's
both julian mcbain says republicans and
libertarians need to dump money into
deep blue districts to see things change
i think that's actually important yeah
you got to go in behind enemy lines and
so
you know as the chairman of the
republican party texas you know you sit
down and you look at the battlefield
and you see what what is the enemy going
to do because you got to base your plan
on what the enemy wants to do so
the democrats wanted to go after the
suburban soccer mom they wanted to go
orange man bad trump is hateful he's a
massages whatever
and so i said let's go into the rio
grande valley we have never gone down
and engaged and let's
connect with the hispanic community and
get them to understand that they're
conservative in nature
and look at what happened and that was
the news story about how we flipped the
rio grande valley
uh in november 2020. right on
a lot of people are mentioning it is
west the number four and texas.com a lot
of people are
posting it so thank you all right let's
uh
we'll get in a couple more sdp says
governor
west wink i'm curious your thoughts on
abbott from tennessee
uh and am milk tim to lukewarm on my
governor and yours
america is craving statesmen again and
it's just about time
well the important thing i always tell
people i'm not running against greg
abbott i'm running for texas
and i want to show an example of
leadership that people will want to
rally to
because it's not about my interest or
special interest it's about the texan
interest
and our tagline for our campaign is
defending the texas republic
because when you think about what a
republic means it means the rule of law
and individual rights freedoms and
liberty right on
ryonin taka says larry elder becoming
governor of cali would make leftist
heads ex literally explode i would pay
large amounts of money to watch it
well you can pay a large of a large
amount of money to help make it happen
i'm sure if larry is
is running i'm sure he takes donations
for his campaign right yeah
i'm sure he will i'm sure he'll have a
website set up but i had heard rumors of
it
uh and i guess it's confirmed i know
that my dear friend herschel walker
is uh moving back to georgia to run for
senate there uh
and i also know that there's a gentleman
another uh black uh republican by the
name of vernon jones who has thrown his
hat in the ring for
running for governor of uh of georgia
and understand this in the history of
the united states of america
there has never been a black republican
elected governor that's right
never that's right wow so now we could
have the chance of three
who do you think who's more powerful
like the mayor of a big city or the
governor
the governor as long as the governor
understands
that they are the governor yeah yeah i
mean look at cuomo you know he was the
governor he killed 15 000 people and got
away with it done
yeah that's right not even the federal
government did anything to stop that
it's amazing anyway thanks for hanging
out everybody
we're going to have a special
members-only uh show coming up
at timcast.com so sign up we're gonna be
talking about the
rainbow blank blank or bleep bleep
monkey and that that fiasco and the
targeting of children the indoctrination
it's it's it's a bit spicy for youtube
so again timcast.com
become a member you can follow the show
on facebook and instagram at tim cast
irl
where you can like the videos and share
them to help you know help us leverage
those networks to build a following and
move them over to the website
we we ultimately don't want to be using
these censorious platforms but we're
going to use
the platform as the best of our
abilities to make teamcast.com big and
massive and do more shows
you can follow me personally at tim cast
and we do the show monday through friday
live at 8 p.m
but i believe uh lieutenant colonel west
you have a website or some social media
you want to shout out yes west4texas.com
the number four
uh we found out that governor abbott's
uh folks bought the website west for
texas. wow hey look you know that shows
that uh
people are kind of nervous and scared
but west the number four texas.com
facebook twitter
youtube instagram all of those platforms
we're out there
right on thanks you can also follow me
ian crossland.net and at ian cross on
social media i want to ask you guys
before we roll
uh have you ever seen band of brothers
of course oh have you seen that no tom
hanks movie about world war
ii what is the uh yeah it's the
documentary of the uh
50 uh six parachute infantry regiment
dude kirahi yeah the best david
schwimmer's in it but you also need to
watch
uh the pacific which is the story of the
marines uh
and all the island hopping uh that they
did oh wow also a true story
have you seen 1917 oh of course i have
amazing it is
it is man yeah yeah wow dude trench
wharf
talk about that movie was yeah we're all
armed with guns united states but trench
warfare
25 000 250 000 frenchmen would die one
day
as 200 000 germans in one day in one
battle the movie is mostly real time
yeah that's amazing yeah mostly
have you been to the antietam
battlefield that's not too far from here
i don't think so
you guys need to go to the i mean that
is the worst day of
military loss in u.s history 22 000 in
one day
so antietam is not far from you all here
and of course gettysburg
is an incredible battlefield it's still
preserved and you get eerie chills
when you stand there and and just you
know being at the little round top or
some of the other places so i've been to
antietam we didn't go to the sites or
anything like that though yeah go to
antiques and go to gettysburg right on
yeah i'm going to be going there this
summer i've been seeing all these signs
i'm like i got to go there i got to go
there i have like a whole list and i'm
going to do it around my birthday i
think
um thank you very much for coming and
sharing your intergenerational wisdom
oh i don't even know what that means but
that's what she called she called you
all
oh god you're welcome uh it is
intergenerational just just go with it
it's fine you're very wise we appreciate
that around here
you guys are welcome to follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter
as i attempt to have more followers than
sourpatch kids
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
and uh this should be a fun members-only
segment coming up we'll see you there
bye guys
you